there's a bill that we haven't
co-sponsored
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
senate bill 202 and hear from the prime
sponsor senator waters good morning
senator waters
thank you mr mr chairman members of the
committee it's good to see you all i'm
senator david waters district four here
to introduce senate bill
202 particular sale cosmetic
products tested on animals um
the heart of this bill i'll just get
right to that is uh on the first page
when it states that no manufacturer
should sell or offer for sale in this
state any cosmetic if such cosmetic was
developed or manufactured using cosmetic
animal testing that was conducted or
contracted for by the manufacturer or
any supplier of the manufacturer so the
purpose of the bill is
is pretty clear that with the
appropriate definitions and with
exceptions as noted throughout the bill
that we want new hampshire consumers to
know that when they purchase a cosmetic
product that it has not been produced
through animal
cruelty in animals that often is
now one might ask you know why does new
hampshire need to do this there is some
federal and international regulation
i think it's very similar to what we
have done on issues like wildlife
trafficking and other animal protection
errors
areas where there is federal statute
perhaps but
the feds are not here to enforce and
pres
in our state so the feds do interstate
we do intrastate so this is a way of
providing assurance to our consumers
that uh products that they want to
purchase have
been done in accordance with the
so
just to go through through some of the
issue the areas where this is set up as
you have the definitions um
set up on the first
page and uh for both what the animal
testing is what a cosmetic is and then
the issue of ingredients here as
as well
and um what you know there needs to be
because of federal statute you'll see
the cfr is referenced here about
manufacturers and non-functional
constituents so this is important to
make sure we're doing this the same
definitions
under federal
federal statute
do note please on page two
uh that there are
important
sections here
um that define the kinds of testing
uh importantly i think on page on page 2
lines 10 11 um
that there's this of course in certain
cases needs to continue if there's no
animal there's no non-animal alternative
method or strategy recognized by any
federal
or state agent agency
and uh that's certainly important
in terms of
human safety that there are perhaps
exceptions here a little bit further
down same thing
line 18 there's no non-animal
alternative method or strategy
recognized by any federal or state
agency once again you have that
down there
um and that the potential again on line
21 recognizing that
sometimes these things
these agents propose a risk of causing a
specific human health problem that's
substantiated and the need to conduct
cosmetics animal testing and justified
so those are important caveats and
provisions there
the other thing i'd like to note as well
that we amended the bill
in the senate because i thought it was
important to hold
harmless new hampshire retailers this is
a similar provision as you may recall
when we're doing the flame retardants
legislation mr chairman we wanted to
make sure that
you know if you're at the tail end of
the supply chain and you're retailer in
new hampshire
and unknown to you that there has been a
violation that you're held harmless for
that and i think that's an important
addition that we made
in the in the senate
um
so
as i said i i think the argument here
about what we're trying to do about
animal uh cosmetic testing is is pretty
clear and is in line with you know
really the bipartisan consensus in both
bodies has developed to try to do what
we can for
for animal protections in in many many
ways um
and uh i think that it also now would
mean that we join at least 8 other
states that number may have increased
that are part of a national
effort to make sure that if interstate
commerces is covered let's make sure the
intra-state commerce is covered
as as well
so i'd be glad to take any questions uh
mr chairman
any questions to the committee we do
have a couple of questions
yes
yes cody sorry thank you thank you
thank you senator for bringing this and
i do have one area that i found a little
bit confusing and that's the exemptions
that have to do with testing
from foreign entities
a foreign regulatory authorities i'm
wondering if you could clarify that in
layman's terms so we can understand how
that exemption works in the state i will
give it a try and then we have kurt
aaron
uh right here as well but um where
which i'm if you could just point page
page one lines 29 30 and then also on
so um
we can't control thank you for your
question we can't con you know we here
in new hampshire can't control what a
foreign
nation is doing under its rules
um
but please note uh halfway through line
30.
it says provided that no evidence
derived from the testing
was relied upon to substantiate the
safety of the cosmetic
ingredient or cosmetic product being
sold by the manufacturer
in new hampshire
so
here's the here's what that means
they might do a process over there
that may involve animal testing
we can't stop or control that
but that study should not be the basis
under which we determine whether or not
so
we want to know we want to be assured
that the actual
safety of that ingredient has determined
by testing
that is in accordance with the other
parts of the bill
that say there's just no
it protects this is a something that
might potentially involve human risk
that there's no non-animal
um
testing possible that otherwise could be
used so do you see what i'm trying to
say is that it it kind of recognizes the
foreign companies going to do that we
can't control what they're going to do
but for that ingredient we're not going
to rely on that to determine whether it
is in accordance with the united states
i'm sorry i have trouble with does does
it mean that you can't use the
ingredient or that we have to do our own
testing
it says that basically what it's trying
to say is that
our decision about whether we use that
ingredient
is not going to be based on
their testing it's going to be based on
testing
that conforms to the assurances
about animal
cosmetic testing that is laid out in the
united states in state statute
thanks thanks for your question i i i'm
sorry it's
you know it i i understand it's a little
complicated but the the point is that we
want to make sure that when we sign off
on something
it has been
that that sign-off is based on testing
that is in accordance with the
provisions here
representative fargo
yes
he'll tell you if i didn't
[Laughter]
uh thank you senator yeah and i
appreciate your testimony today but i'm
confused because
i thought the purpose of this was not to
purchase anything
i why
why would
okay so we don't rely on that
information but we're still if we know
that animals were used why would we
why would we even
i don't understand why we would even
have this here
i would think just the fact that they
tested on animals would be enough to say
that we wouldn't want to purchase that
particular
well
thanks for your question and um i
i know we that many of us might wish
that this never occurred
at all
however
um there are occasions
where
the the medical industry
or others who are testing various
components that the only way you can
make sure that it is safe is through
animal testing that's why on page two
you have that um
your own lines 18 to 20 and the other
place as well that if
indeed
under international and federal statute
that it is demonstrated that there is
absolutely no other way to determine the
safety is something that is an essential
pro essential
component
then
animal testing
is allowed now i i may not like it or so
but i think you can understand the
arguments that sometimes for
human safety and you know
um certain kind of development of
pharmaceuticals and so on that that's
that's the
that's the guard rail
yeah but i i i know what you're saying
but there there it is thank you yeah
representative bartlett
thanks very much um i do notice and you
made a good point senator that this is a
bipartisan bill can you tell me what the
vote was in the senate this came through
representative burroughs
thank you
thanks for taking my question senator
and forgive please tell me if this was
asked while i was out of the room for a
minute but um i did read that there are
alternatives to human testing is that
something that was asked previously
thanks for your question
uh yeah i mean what the point of kind of
what the bill tries to outline is that
it's that we want
these products to be produced without
animal testing that's the bottom line
then there's a however
there are certain exceptions that are
recognized internationally and through
federal statute
that we kind of
boil our plate into here because
you know they are federal they are
federal statutes but the point is to
make this as absolutely tight as
possible so that new hampshire consumers
know
what they're buying has not been
produced through
animal cruelty
i'll follow up for the question main
choir okay
here's i'll duo would you believe
that you know i did read that some of
the alternatives to human testing are
using human cells and tissues computer
modeling and
human volunteers
is there any way that we could
somehow incorporate that into the
component with the federal with with um
products coming in to see if in fact
there are alternatives than using
animals to test
thank you for your your question and you
know thank goodness the technologies are
changing right that um you know what
that really has been a transformation
uh about
you know what kind of testing because
people recognize the
sometimes they're just plain unnecessary
and certainly it is often cruel
um
i think that what you see in the bill
and that language there is that there
are processes that are in place to say
you have to prove you have to prove
there's no alternative
and um
any other representative
thank you mr chair thank you senator for
bringing this to us
uh how many other states
have this
in statute right now
thanks for your question um i i
reference to my testimony eight others
but i i did know the last time i checked
that which i think was december or
january that there were other bills and
several other states had other bills in
process so that it's possible that kirk
can give you an update on that
thank you senator
i think major i think new jersey i mean
some pretty major states where there's a
big
pharmaceutical and cosmetic industry is
based so
i know new jersey is huge yeah
thank you
oh
representative fargo has another
question
um yes and thank you um
i see that you're excluding retailers in
the state of new hampshire and i can
understand the motivation behind that
but what if that what if that retailer
is a manufacturer here in new hampshire
i'm sorry what if what if the retailer
in new hampshire is actually also the
manufacturer of the cosmetic in new
hampshire
um well they would be covered and we're
going to we have some folks here from
badger to talk about this so that will
be a good thank you and mr chairman i've
got 49 fourth graders waiting for me
but i want you to know i'll be in big
trouble if i don't go all those
questions came from the other side of
the aisle
but um the real experts are behind me
but thank you so much and um if there
are further questions uh please be in
touch
thank you thank you mr chairman okay
uh so uh chair will call on kurt ernberg
who represents the humane society of the
united states and he can
good morning
mr chairman members of the committee i'm
kurt ehrenberg i'm the new hampshire
state director for the humane society of
the united states
i appreciate your uh having me
here to testify this morning um i did
submit testimony electronically
i have it here
um i also have
wanted to bring to your attention
five
small businesses in new hampshire that
submitted letters hopefully you've
received them electronically
um
lush cosmetics has two stores in new
hampshire
portsmouth soap company in portsmouth
the refill station which is a cosmetics
retailer in
portsmouth um
[Music]
and the
hemlock spring soap company
in nashua
as well as badger who are here to speak
for themselves
uh recently the concord monitor the
union leader and the keen sentinel all
ran
uh editorial op-ed opposition op-eds on
on this issue
from the badger bomb
hierarchy
ceos
so
and i think you'll see on online today
there's an enormous amount of support
for this bill
um
so my uh written testimony i will read
um stop me if i get to be too long i'm
happy to take any questions um
so i do appreciate the opportunity to
submit this written testimony
uh on behalf of the humane society of
the united states and our new hampshire
members and supporters urging the
committee to pass sb 202
this legislation does prohibit the sale
in new hampshire of any cosmetic
for which a new animal test was
conducted or contracted by
on behalf of the manufacturer or any
supplier of the manufacturer after
january first of 2023.
sb 202
does not contain
or does contain limited exceptions that
allow for animal testing under certain
conditions including testing done to
satisfy regulatory requirements and to
address specific and serious human
health concerns
there is strong corporate support for
ending cosmetics animal testing sb 202
has received letters of support from
cosmetics manufacturers and retailers as
i said
federal legislators are currently
considering the humane cosmetics act
bipartisan legislation to end the
production and sale of animal tested
cosmetics
the humane society
legislative fund and the personal care
products council the leading national
trade association representing 90
percent
of the u.s cosmetics industry joined
together to support this legislation in
an unprecedented agreement
to bring about an end to cosmetic animal
testing in the united states
in addition to
pcpc which represents approximately 600
member companies
370 individual companies have endorsed
this federal effort sb 202 was drafted
to mirror the provisions found in this
federal legislation and i just point out
this federal legislation
for whatever reason as many
initiatives in congress has hit a dead
end is stalled is not moving
as was said earlier there are eight
states hopefully new hampshire will join
them
to this momentum toward a more humane
way of testing cosmetics
animal testing is totally unnecessary
it's cruel and not a reliable predictor
it's cruel and it's not a reliable
predictor of human responses
in traditional animal tests rabbits
guinea pigs and mice and rats
have substances forced down their
throats
dripped into their eyes or smeared onto
their skin before they are killed
these test methods are unreliable
predictors of human safety
different species can respond
differently when exposed to the same
chemicals
consequently animal tests may under or
overestimate real world hazards to
people
in addition results from animal tests
can be quite variable
and difficult to interpret
so they know they don't serve their
purpose
anyway
so
why would you be for these you know not
making a law against
manufacturers
selling these products in new hampshire
this is not a bill that holds harmless
any retailer
any consumer
it is about the manufacturer and you'll
hear from one of them
soon
um
so this is completely unnecessary
there's no animal testing requirements
for cosmetic
safety substantiation in the united
states companies can already create
great products using thousands of
available ingredients that have a
history of safe use and do not require
new testing
for new ingredients where animal testing
may currently be
used many non-animal methods have been
and continue to be developed
non-animal methods can combine human
cell-based tests and sophisticated
computer models to deliver human
relevant results at less cost and in
less time than traditional animal tests
there has been a global trend toward
eliminating cosmetic animal testing in
2018 california became the first state
in the country to ban the sale of
cosmetics newly tested on animals
followed by nevada and illinois in 2019
so on and so forth and i won't bore you
with all the list of countries that we
have here
so the humane society of the united
states strongly supports sb 202 and
urges the committee to pass this
legislation
to make new hampshire the next state to
address the unnecessary cruelty of
and
i'm happy to take questions
uh we do have questions
well from on the left side now so
representative griezmann so i'll let you
go first
thank you mr chairman and thank you sir
for uh
for coming in this morning
do these new non-animal testing methods
use fetal tissues as their primary
source of human cells
not to my knowledge and i don't know i'm
not
an expert on that okay
can you tell us the eight states that
hopefully
uh
virginia maryland maine hawaii new
jersey
how many is that one two three four five
uh california nevada illinois
is that eight
okay there you go grub cemetery thank
you uh mr chairman uh thank you sir for
your uh testimony uh
i think for the record it would be safe
to
assume that
no one on this
committee
subscribes to
the type of testing that you're seeking
to outlaw with this legislation
and that would also include inhumane
testing on human beings which we know
i believe you had indicated
in your testimony earlier in your
remarks that there was resistance
at the federal level
and i want to make sure that that i was
correct in hearing that
but so that i don't have to do a
follow-up um request i'll just continue
if you don't mind
um
our
i with many of my purchases i notice
the the label cruelty free on the on the
products
are are you aware of of uh and can you
identify companies that are resistant uh
to this and also any companies
that have been prosecuted because of
their uh
failure to comply
with the laws that have been enacted
today in any of the 41 countries
or any of the states that have passed
legislation and i'm wondering how it was
determined that they
uh or what that they were charged on
what basis they were charged and
a thank you in advance for the answer to
your question i appreciate it mr
chairman i yield back the balance of my
time
okay it's my turn
all right
i appreciate the question i uh
so first of all
the answer is i'm not aware i'm not
prepared to
to answer that right now
but
the bill
holds the manufacturer and only the
manufacturer responsible
for this bill that if they did
inadvertently sell some product that
did not meet the requirements of this
law they would not be responsible but
the manufacturer would be and there are
fines and spelled out in the in the bill
what the remedy for that is
um
we have in new hampshire the may i would
say one of the major if not the largest
cosmetic manufacturer in the state ready
to testify here today that you know
they're willing to take on that
responsibility
um i don't
frankly see why there's any reason
why new hampshire would not join
the only uh
the only entity that is
at risk here is the manufacturer
and the real benefit here is that the
consumer of new hampshire
every time they go and take something
off the shelf then do not have to worry
that it may say on the label
i mean i have the shampoo i use this
morning says
this product was not tested on animals
but
you know most people in their shopping
do not check that and they can rest
assured once this is passed and signed
into law that in new hampshire
everything you buy illegally is not
good
thank you very much oh rep
who
will make sure that these manufacturers
are in compliance
which what entity what state entity or
what federal entity well i i would say
like any other uh and there are many i
would think and the chairman would know
better than i
but there are statutes that you would
have to make a complaint to the attorney
general or some
authority if you were if you ran into i
hopefully the consumer would be our best
uh
police person on this if they uh
noticed something and in terms of the
issue of a foreign manufacturer
um
so note so what this bill says is no
test can be used
to verify
uh safety
no animal test can be used to verify if
safe doesn't know where or when or how
or who
did it
it cannot be used to verify the safety
of the product
great great thank you very much
appreciate your time thank you
all right i have one more card here uh
deidra fitzgerald representing the ws
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for having me here
today
i'm deirdre or d fitzgerald i'm the
communications manager at ws badger
located in gilson new hampshire
i'm here today to express our strong
support for sb 202 which would prohibit
the sale of cosmetic products that have
been tested on animals
there is no reason for the continued use
of animal test methods in the united
states when cosmetic products can be
created using thousands of ingredients
that have already been proven to be safe
ws badger has been producing cruelty
free organic skin care in the state of
new hampshire since 1995 so that's 27
years
of putting out cruelty free products
we employ a hundred people and we are an
employer of choice
for new hampshire consumers this bill
ensures that they don't have to think
twice about the cosmetics that they're
shopping for as a manufacturer we've
held high standards
on our manufacturing our good
manufacturing practices
and we have had the cruelty-free
designation for all of our 27 years
our customers expect it they demand it
and we see that consumers
are growing there's a growing demand by
consumers for that cruelty-free mark or
that cruelty-free statement
for
personal care cosmetics
this bill does not impact retailers we
are a manufacturer we are
a manufacturer who sells a cosmetic
product
uh we would not have been doing this for
27 years if there was a risk
to our business
the passing of this bill is going to put
new hampshire
along with eight other states which kurt
mentioned earlier um in the right
we
feel this is really important
for new ingredients but that are being
used in cosmetic products there are many
non-animal test methods available that
can be used for safety evaluations which
was mentioned earlier these alternatives
provide data that is more relevant to
humans and offer savings in time and
cost from traditional animal tests
as was mentioned before there are
already eight states we'd like new
hampshire to be the ninth if possible
um and we strongly urge you to support
sb202 and i promised to make this short
and sweet and that was everything
great thank you representative johnson
as a question
thank you thank you for taking my
question and testifying today
um
kind of on the long same lines what do
you use for
your testing
of your product is it um the human fetal
tissue
no we do not so what are some of the
items that you use to testing so we use
volunteers human volunteers we are an
organic skincare company so many of our
products are sourced are certified
organic
we make bombs and solves we if we make
soaps
they are also tested on humans not
volunteer humans not on any fetal tissue
or
also we use
past data to prove that those
ingredients are safe for human use so
any other questions uh representative
greeson
thank you mr chairman and and thank you
i'm assuming that's probably like badger
balm is that two two you made yeah so we
make it's ws badger company but we go by
badger and we make um a line of salves
and we also make sunscreen and other
personal care products in your in your
testing i i ask that because my my son
always requires us to send him care
packages with badger ball
[Laughter]
because he can't get it down in new
hampshire camp lejeune you should
probably expand your market
uh in your in your in your testing
what happens when something goes wrong
can you define that you are testing new
ingredients
and you you've made this promise to not
use animal testing but you're using
volunteer humans
what happens when something goes wrong
one of those ingredients
produces some kind of
adverse reaction right how how do you
handle that who do you report that to
who is regulating that yeah all that
stuff so so who are you held accountable
to sure in your testing so we are
certified cruelty free which means we
actually hold it as a standard we have a
third party
that
ensures that we are following
you know cruelty free methods as far as
ingredient safety we have a very high
standard of checking the ingredients
that we source in to our company and we
use
in our products we also check those
ingredients
throughout the life cycle of the product
so
you know if there's any chance of a
reaction
we are constantly checking to make sure
that's not going to happen
and we are also
if for example someone may have
we do make a sore muscle rub which has
cayenne pepper we put a warning on our
packaging that says you know please spot
test this product before using
but as far as cruelty free again we are
held to a standard by the cruelty-free
designation
and you're also a b corporation we are
also certified b corporation thank you
yeah
thank you very much thank you thank you
uh having no more cards uh the blue
sheet for sign in
uh
damaris
also from badger and then linda dion
and all all
were in support of the bill
and over overnight we had 56
in support in three people in opposition
and with that i will close the public
hearing
okay
okay we're all ready to open up public
hearing on senate bill 35 and i see i do
have a senator senator burjell good
good morning mr chair good morning
committee thank you for hearing
senate bill 355
for the record my name is regina
bertsell i'm
a state senator from district 19 which
encompasses the towns
of derry hampstead in windham
and
i am here as the prime sponsor of senate
bill 355.
it's requiring online market places to
disclose
certain information to consumers
before i begin my testimony i do want to
thank the advocates for the new
hampshire retail association
walmart and amazon
for working on the amended compromise on
355 that we did during in the senate
that is before you today and it's good
to have all the players on the same page
new hampshire consumers have every
reason to expect that goods on local
stores local store shelves are safe and
authentic
but the same may not be true of the most
some of the online shopping platforms
a flood of counterfeit merchandise is
now being sold on e-commerce platforms
putting
new hampshire residents in harm's way
products like toys clothing electronic
devices computers cosmetic products
handbags watches cigarettes and even
prescription drugs have been known to
shopping
we have all heard about the glut of the
fake night and 95 mass that were being
sold during the pandemic and over the
past few months we have
seen news reports of smash and grab
thefts at retail stores where the stolen
merchandise ends up on sale on some of
these platforms
there have been a number of articles on
have copies of them i can
make copies and have them to the
chair so that he can he can review them
too and give it to the committee
with the health and safety of new
hampshire residents and businesses on
the on the line senate bill 5 355 offers
a practical solution that will provide
a boost of transparency where it is
desperately needed
senate bill 355 would require e-commerce
platforms to verify high-volume
third-party sellers and also establish a
notification to concern consumers
disclosing where the high-volume seller
is located and how they can be contacted
this will go a long way to wean out
those who masquerade as legitimate
sellers and dupe our citizens into
purchasing fake faulty or stolen goods
their similar legislation has been
introduced around the country and
support has come from cvs home depot
walgreens walmart by safe america
coalition kroger's lowe's dick's
um so i urge you to support this
balanced approach to help protect new
hampshire's consumers and i will attempt
to take any questions
representative bartlett has a question
thanks so much for recognizing me thanks
for coming before us
um i've got a question
yesterday i was listening to nhpr and
the
um some of the
average or
people that that
sell through este
have got a week-long and they're calling
it a strike even though they're really
independent
sellers
would this bill
affect
those that actually make a product and
then
if somebody were to buy it
and you know like a whole bunch of them
and then try to resell them
i think someone behind me coming up can
testify to that but i do understand that
if essie has a number of
just just like a walmart or an amazon if
they have an if sd has a number of
um
[Music]
providers
that yes they will probably have to have
the um the information required of
amazon walmart online
um home depot online any of them um
for the question main car thanks so
do you think this might protect those i
mean for the most part the sd
um
sellers are small
are small operators right um they make
their own product um and they're not
reselling
other people's products do you think
this might protect
okay i can't answer that i understand
sorry thank you
okay uh representative terry yes uh
thank you
so uh do i understand that
currently there is no liability
or only weak liability
uh for on the part of the for example
the amazons of the world with respect to
third-party sellers if i purchase
something that's sold by a third-party
seller on amazon amazon is in the free
and clear right now or is are there weak
protections what what's what's going on
from my understanding there are there
are no protections for uh consumers who
purchase
um
who purchase these items either smash
okay thanks
thank you very much
before i call on curtis uh we have a
more important person in the room that i
like to call
and that's brandon garrett from the
department of justice
because we want him to get back out
there and
possible i appreciate it i don't know if
i would acknowledge that i'm more
important than anything
say we're all important
uh good morning mr chairperson members
of the committee brandon garage chief of
the consumer protection and antitrust
bureau at the new hampshire attorney
general's office
attorney general's office is here
neither in support or against this bill
just to provide information to the
committee and also a couple of potential
enforcement problems that i see that i
think there is probably a remedy to
um but i would like to start just by
saying that you know in response to the
question that was just asked and
something that's probably on everybody's
mind
is that this is a real problem
we regularly receive complaints from
consumers where they purchase something
on an online platform
and there's little to no recourse
because it was purchased from a third
party seller who's not expressly you
know a member of the online marketplace
the online marketplace essentially punts
responsibility to the third-party seller
and the third-party seller can't be
identified contacted or prosecuted
so it's a large problem for the attorney
general's office in having the ability
to identify and prosecute third-party
sellers who are online
who are selling counterfeit goods
so just as a general idea that we should
be having laws in place that provides
accountability for third-party sellers
and you know
identification for third-party sellers
i think that's a good thing and i think
that this is a significant step in the
right direction um i just want to be
clear about some hurdles that i would
see from an enforcement perspective at
the attorney general's office as we
would be expected to investigate and
prosecute any non-compliance
with this bill i also want to say um
apologize you i we did not testify in
the senate and that is because when i
originally reviewed this bill
i saw as largely a good thing that i
thought would work and i received a
number of phone calls this week asking
me various questions about this so i
took a second look um and
i think there are a couple of
enforcement hurdles that should at least
be brought to the attention of the
committee so that potentially they could
be addressed
the way that this would work or at least
the way that i would see this working
from a consumer protection bureau
enforcement standpoint
is if a consumer bought something
on amazon or on walmart.com or any of
the large online marketplaces um that
have what has been designated as um high
volume third-party sellers by this bill
and the what they got ended up being
counterfeit um and they
this bill would put the the initial
burden on the consumer to contact the
online on the online marketplace in
order to obtain the contact information
um for the person that sold them the
goods um and the online marketplace
would then have an obligation to provide
that information
um what would happen is that the
consumer would file a complaint with the
attorney general's office and would say
i bought this thing and it was fake
the attorney general's office would not
be in any position at that point to
identify whether the third party seller
involved
met the definition of a high volume
third party seller which has that
reporting requirement
to the online marketplace so our
recourse would be to send a subpoena say
to amazon that says identify you know
everything in your possession regarding
this seller and specifically identify
whether they are an online third-party
seller
we would if amazon was not compliant
with that or you know you said they're
not a high volume third-party seller we
would have no way to know whether they
were being truthful or not short of
subpoenaing their sales records
in order to determine whether that
person actually met the definition of an
online third-party seller and those are
all you know multiple steps that take
multiple months that would cause a
substantial delay and a hurdle to
investigation and prosecution i think
that you know that can be resolved if
there was some sort of mechanism that
required
online marketplaces to identify
and label
these high-volume third-party sellers to
consumers on the front end so that a
consumer that's going on amazon or is
going to walmart.com going on ebay any
of these marketplaces can choose to do
business only with those who have been
designated as high volume third party
sellers so that they know that if
something goes wrong this business is
going to have the requirement to provide
them with the contact information for
their business that has been verified in
accordance with this law
that would give us as the attorney
general's office if we received a
complaint knowledge that
the online marketplace had identified
this third party seller as a high volume
third party seller and therefore would
have that contact information that
should be provided to the consumer
and if then they then didn't
it would give the attorney general's
office the ability to investigate and
prosecute non-compliance with their
obligation to obtain verify and provide
contact information for high-volume
third-party sellers to consumers i know
that was very wordy i think that was the
most concise way i could possibly say it
but i think the the takeaway is that in
order for this to be enforceable in a in
a swift and manageable way i think there
needs to be some requirement for the
online marketplace to identify
either to the consumers or to the
attorney general's office on the front
end who are their high-volume
third-party sellers so that if a
consumer is having trouble getting
contact information from that business
for a particular seller um
we'd be able to identify that issue a
subpoena and investigate accordingly
the
only other issue that i see potentially
is
there's a carve out in here
which is that if the high volume third
party seller certifies the online
marketplace that the seller does not
have a business address and only has a
residential street address
or a business address and a residential
address the online marketplace may
disclose only the country and if
applicable the state in which the high
volume third party seller resides i just
want to make clear that if that's the
case and that's the only information
that's being provided that we would
essentially be left without
an ability to take the next step and
investigate and prosecute who that
online third-party seller was
if all we have is the state in which
they reside or the country in which they
reside oftentimes that is the
information that we have and we need
more than that in order to initiate an
investigation of the actual third-party
seller it wouldn't be under this
provision but certainly selling
counterfeit merchandise online to new
hampshire residents as a potential
violation of
the consumer protection act's standing
prohibition of unfair and deceptive acts
or practices so if we were going to take
this information that's provided
the contact information for the actual
person that's doing the wrong here an
initiated investigation we would need
more than simply the state that they're
located in or the country that they're
located in order to do that so i just
wanted to make that very clear
i think that you know the only other
thing you know
the committee is
not going to be surprised to hear this
from me um there was a
fiscal note that was done on this and it
always raises the questions of resources
um
it's unclear what additional resources
if any would be needed in order to to
effectively prosecute this we simply
don't know the volume of the complaints
that it may generate or the scale of the
investigations that we would need to
undertake in order to enforce this so i
just think it's always important to
remind the the committee that a
significant addition like this may
require in the future additional
resources for the consumer protection
bureau in order to effectively enforce
it um and make sure that its provisions
are upheld and with that i feel that
i've been talking for close to a century
and we'd be happy to take any questions
from any members of the community okay
uh representative patusek is first up uh
thank you for mr chair and thank you for
testifying i have a question you just
brought up a point and about not being
able to dig into and find your
source
do you need subpoena power through this
bill
so if this bill works the way it's
intended to work
and you have a high volume third party
seller who is providing information to
consumers the way that they're required
to under the terms of this bill
the process would go that the consumer
who was deceived or wronged would
contact i'll use amazon just for the
sake of a hypothetical and say i
purchased from a high volume third party
seller please identify to me
the name address telephone number
contact information for this business
assuming that amazon then complied and
provided the consumer with that
information
that information could be provided to
the attorney general's office in the
form of a consumer complaint and we
would be able to know who we're
investigating we wouldn't need to issue
any subpoenas in that regard um
certainly we may then choose to issue
subpoenas against the third party seller
who's the wrong doer in the course of
that investigation uh we would have the
authority to do that under 358 a and you
know the rights and remedies that are
available under that section but the
hurdle in these cases is identifying the
third party seller
oftentimes when we receive these
complaints we simply are not able to do
that and know who we are prosecuting
where they're located or how to go about
contacting um serving that person with a
subpoena serving that person with a
civil complaint or you know bringing
that person to trial to stand uh
and face criminal charges which that's
the bevy of our remedies under the
consumer protection act you need to know
who you're investigating who you're
prosecuting and this bill i think does a
really nice job of creating a solution
whereby that information could be easily
provided to consumers and to the
attorney general's office for that exact
purpose um just here to point out some
potential issues that i see so i hope
that answers your question
representative terry ah thank you mr
chairman uh thank you for
uh your your uh concise and clear uh
description
of an issue that you have uh uncovered
with respect to the mechanism i believe
is the term you use
to identify
high-volume third-party sellers
so in view the fact that that mechanism
is not contained within this bill at
this time
would you be willing to work with this
committee on
drafting and uh an amendment
to it
that would address
the very real need
that i believe you you've convinced me
of
that would
make this
uh this bill and if it were to be
enacted into law actually something that
could work and overcome the hurdle i
think is the term of use or
perhaps even the roadblock of
identifying who in fact are third-party
sellers and i understand what you've
said is that you would place that upon
the um
the middleman so to speak walmart the
platform amazon so forth would you be
willing to do that so i
am limited in my ability to you know
formally commit to that as i would need
the attorney general's approval in order
to do that but you know as i said i
think that the intent of this bill is
really good i think that the intent of
this bill addresses a need that the
consumer protection bureau sees on a
daily basis so i would certainly um be
willing to discuss and recommend to the
attorney general that we do that but i
would need his ultimate approval before
we were able to do that certainly open
to it follow and and you will you'll do
that
i will thank you yes
representative burroughs excuse me
representative bartlett what's before
you
thank you mr chair um i was just looking
at some of the information that's been
supplied
to us regarding this bill
um do you think it's realistic
for new hampshire
to require a company like amazon
to supply the kind of information you
would need
to
do i think it's realistic that amazon
could provide contact information for
its third-party sellers to new hampshire
yeah i do you do okay good thing i i i i
mean
i think the bill limits what needs to be
provided to verified contact information
for the individuals who are using the
online marketplace to sell their
merchandise and if there's a
verification and identification process
in place for you know you're going to
sell on this platform so therefore you
need to provide your name your address
your telephone number your email address
your physical location
that information should be
recorded verified and easily provided
hopefully voluntarily by worst-case
scenario in response to a subpoena under
the consumer protection act i certainly
don't
tend to or represent that i can speak
for those businesses to talk about how
reasonable it might be or what the cost
might be associated with doing that but
from my perspective i i would think that
providing that sort of contact
information would be a reasonable
undertaking
for the question main choir thank you um
so have you had occasion
to have to approach amazon with any of
the complaints
that you've previously had
regarding this issue
i i can't speak to amazon specifically
but we have i can say with confidence
that we have received consumer
complaints against online marketplaces
um
i can't recall whether it was there was
a counterfeit good or that it was not
represented it did not appear in the way
it was represented but there was an
issue with the good that was sold and
we've made efforts to you know subpoena
the information from the marketplace and
we were unsuccessful in doing so okay
thanks
representative burroughs
thank you for taking my question this is
a quick question let's just
hypothetically say you have a bad actor
in kazakhstan and you know it's in
kazakhstan but there's no way you're
gonna be able to
go after this person is there a way to
do you have a remedy to remove them from
the marketplace or would that be like up
to amazon to do that
so
do we have a remedy
potentially we
could but it is a very very long process
that would you know
require us filing a suit against the
online marketplace and asking the court
for injunctive relief in the form of
removing the individual we could do it
but you know ultimately the marketplace
is in a much much better position to do
it and in order for us to
take on the role of suing amazon suing
walmart suing ebay every time there's a
bad actor that's reported that's in
another country to have them remove
the the
additional resources we would need to do
something like that are astronomical
the
i think the problem with a lot of these
third-party sellers is that they are in
other countries um and can't be easily
identified so prosecuting them
identifying them is a huge hurdle so for
for each one of those reports it would
not be realistic to think that the
attorney general alone
could
sue to have them removed every single
time that this comes up it requires a
different problem and i think the burden
of that is probably more easily placed
on the company that is allowing them to
sell on their platforms which i believe
is part of the intent of what this
legislation tries to do
representative johnson
hi thank you for taking my question so
i understand the concept of of the bill
and i
part of me understands it my question is
how
you know amazon and
you know home depot and all of these
they they aren't they're online they're
not here in new hampshire they're all
over
how do we control something that's not
in our state
it's online it's virtual
so that's why i'm trying to understand
how we can have those rules on somebody
who doesn't was you know isn't here
physically
you know i believe that those businesses
that you just identified while they do
have you know a large online presence
they are also physically present in
doing business in new hampshire i mean i
believe each of the businesses you just
identified maintains a physical business
presence within the state and is
therefore subject to the laws of the
state
for the question main choir so even
though it's online and it's not in their
physical location stores they're not
buying you know someone's not going to
their store and buying it they're
actually going online and purchasing it
it would still
they would still fall under this because
they're physically here even amazon
amazon does have my understanding it
does have a physical presence within the
state
and
if a business is choosing to do business
in new hampshire there's a is a legal
standard
for whether somebody's conduct
sufficiently rises to the level of
reaching into the state in order to
you know do business in the state so
that they're subject to our laws
if they have a physical presence in the
state i think there's a very strong and
compelling argument that they are
subject to all of the laws of the state
as
as it uh pertains to
commerce and doing business in the state
if you have a business that is purely a
hundred percent let's say in california
that sells online and sells you know
everywhere
and you know makes the decision to sell
to new hampshire even though they don't
physically come to new hampshire have a
building in new hampshire
i personally believe that there is still
an argument that could be made that by
making the decision to sell and ship to
new hampshire that they are still doing
business in new hampshire sufficiently
to subject themselves to these laws but
that is an issue that would probably
need to be litigated down the road but i
i think there's a strong argument for it
um
representative below
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
the when the bill was drafted
by the
senators i'm not sure who the other
sponsors are do they
when there's a bill um
making the judicial
branch
are there
were this set let's say this year where
the several bills this year um did they
come to you to help draft the bill
because it does really reflect on your
capacity to
you know make it happen
so it's it's a little bit of a difficult
question for me to answer there are
certainly occasions in every legislative
season where our office receives
requests to help draft legislation for a
variety of reasons however you know the
attorney general's office is a member of
the executive branch
not of the judicial branch
not the legislative branch so we we you
know like to come over and you know
speak to you know if we're going to be
enforcing this law how we think or even
if we're not how this
you know particular legislation may
contradict or may fall in line with or
may you know but heads with other laws
in the state or whether it affects the
work that we're doing in in our office
but the policy of you know
how to draft a bill what language should
be in it a large portion of that the
attorney general's office is not
involved in just because we we are not
the legislature we don't write the laws
we enforce them um but certainly if
somebody reaches out and says you know
what do you think about this is this
enforceable we we do our best to be
helpful in that case
it happens sometimes it does not happen
all the time okay thank you so uh on
your note on that note we do have rule
making in this statute
and you guys do rule making right don't
you do something don't you have condo
rules or didn't you guys you you
generated some rules haven't you we've
generated a few rules okay because i'd
say the secretary of state does not like
to regenerate rules we've had that
problem so but yeah okay so the only
other question just help me out here
because um
you made a comment that if the if um if
amazon could identify on their web page
you know who was a a third party
and
uh distributed supplier rather than them
um this would be a lot easier to to
overcome that first question that you
would have to pose to them
i i personally find that that i can
usually sniff that out by how quickly it
gets shipped if it's amazon it gets
shipped the next day if it's going to
wake take a week or two i find that
that's probably a third party company
but notwithstanding that here's my
problem
what your amazon is leaving it to the
third parties
policies
so if the third party's return policy is
all sales are final
even if you were able to identify with
them even though you got all this
information because they have that
policy on their books how does this bill
fix that problem
well if you if you're transacting with a
third party seller that plainly
discloses to the consumer that all sales
are final there would be no problem to
address i mean if it's clearly they
don't clearly they don't yeah clearly
they don't do that but that's a very
different question from you know all
sales are final but if you're selling
something that's counterfeit or you're
selling something that is deceptively
marketed to the consumers that's a
violation of the prohibition of unfair
and deceptive acts or practices so
regardless of whether it violates you
know the businesses return policy if
what you're doing is inducing a consumer
to buy something with false
representations that they wouldn't
otherwise provide that's a problem
regardless of what the return policy the
return policy wouldn't be the question
it's whether that third-party seller had
deceived consumers tricked them
essentially into buying a product that
was other than how it was represented
whether it be counterfeit or simply
looks different or it's a different size
or different quality whatever it is
i believe that the purpose of this bill
is so that if a consumer purchases
something that is not what it claimed to
be on the website um
they have a mechanism to identify the
third party sellers contact them deal
directly with them because right now
i i know we've received a lot of
complaints from consumers who try to
contact
the marketplace the large company and
the actual manufacturer they're told
well it's a third party so you have to
deal with third party but there's no
easy way to identify the third party in
order to deal with them which is is the
underlying so the hope is that at that
point the consumer will find out who the
actual third party is even though they
might be in china they might be at least
they know who they are and they'll have
a maybe an email or some way to contact
them
sorry but then how do they prosecute if
it's a if it's a
fake
well i mean it creates an obligation to
verify which you know the businesses
would have to figure out how they're
going to you know have a verification
process for their high volume third
party sellers so because if they're if
they're not doing that it's a potential
violation of the statute which is an
unfair deceptive act exactly
um so you i think the idea is probably
that if the
marketplace is required to collect and
verify information for its high volume
third-party sellers that the
marketplaces will do a better job of
deciding who they can and can't allow to
sell on their platforms
if they can't verify the information so
if it's fake information through that
verification process the marketplace in
theory um would be able to
realize that and so the idea is
hopefully remove the seller before
enticing it is to make the companies
think twice before they sign somebody up
in their products
hopefully they'll i'm not sure i would
phrase it that way but it is it's the
intent is to have some accountability
so that there is transparency for
consumers about who they are actually
doing business with when they log into
amazon.com or walmart.com consumers
often think they're doing business with
walmart or doing business with amazon
you have to look i mean it usually is
disclosed this is a third-party seller
but you have to look carefully in order
to find out who it is and it usually
discloses it in the in the form of a
business name uh not in the name of a
not in the form of an actual name of a
person or an address for the person or a
telephone number for the person figuring
out who is ultimately responsible is
very difficult for consumers and frankly
very difficult for the attorney
general's office so i think that is the
problem that this bill seeks to um
remedy and i i i would speak just
briefly to you you made a comment about
rulemaking certainly this does give us
the ability to make rules um and we do
we do rule making um but
you spoke about the the condominiums
um when you have statutes and you have
rules and you have to understand the
interplay between the statutes and the
rules and make sure that both line up
and both are consistent it's much much
trickier to enforce and understand than
if the the statute itself just clearly
anticipates the potential issues uh and
deals with them on the on the front end
certainly we're not we're not afraid of
rule making we do rule making we'd be
happy to do rule making if it was
appropriate but i i think the goal
should be to to not have to necessitate
that in order to clean up something um
that probably could be easily resolved
on the front end i 100 agree with you
thank you representative burroughs has
another question
thank you mr chair this is a more of a
would you believe relative to what you
brought up um i'm looking on amazon's
site and it says their a to z guarantee
will protect you when you buy items sold
and fulfilled by a third-party seller
and i think most major companies like
walmart cvs etc do the same thing so you
probably don't have to deal with that if
you get garbage from some third party
is that true
i certainly am not in a position to
speak to
every side
but in your experience you've had amazon
say that's a third-party manufacturer so
we don't take responsibility for their
uh i can't speak to whether that
specific guarantee was in place at the
time that the you know i don't have
dates in the back of my mind i've been
in this position now for
um
coming up on like either three or four
years i can't recall and you know i
don't know how long that's been in place
i don't know if it was in place at the
time that we received the specific
complaints or if the complaints were
even against amazon i'm just speaking
generally about you know we receive
thousands of complaints every year and i
review every single one of them so based
on
my history of doing that there have been
complaints against marketplaces where
this was an issue i can't speak to
whether it was i guess i'm on the i've
always thought that one of the reasons i
am an amazon prime member is hey i get
free shipping and b if anything does not
meet i don't have to give an excuse
i should be able to return it i just
assume everything was returnable but
that's where i guess i'm a little lost
here but representative terry you have
another mr chair uh not that i need to
to validate the information that
representative burroughs has shared but
by personal experience
amazon has has always stood behind
any uh issue
with a third-party seller and i've
received an immediate refund over the
telephone right away
so um apparently
that while this may be an issue we're
also seeing that the third party the the
marketplace the the platform amazon for
example and and yes i believe even
walmart on one or two occasions uh has
stepped up and said look if if we are
uh putting forward these third-party
sellers
we believe we have a responsibility uh
and we will take care of this you'll get
your money we'll deal with a third party
seller i'm not saying that this
legislation is unnecessary but um amazon
and walmart are are not
claiming in my experience that um
they're that they have no responsibility
whatsoever quite to the contrary we'll
leave that as a would you believe
all right but thank you very much thank
you all thank you i appreciate it okay
uh curtis berry representing new
hampshire retail association in support
thank you and i had to check the clock
to make sure it was still morning but it
is uh good morning members of the
committee i'm curtis barry here on
behalf of the new hampshire retail
association
which members know
represents retailers both large and
small
in support of the bill um
i have
mr chair two preface statements i think
uh the first one is to maybe get us back
to
what the purpose of the bill does in
some of what it does
i think my testimony that i prepared
will answer some of the questions
particularly represent bartlett's
question about etsy representative terry
had a question in there some of that
will be answered and i'm happy to expand
on that if it doesn't clear it up
but a couple of points i'd like to make
at the outset first this is not new
hampshire specific language the language
that you see here and by the way i've
distributed two documents two color
documents that you should have one's a
flow chart of how the bill is intended
to work the other one is a map of the
united states showing the progress of
this legislation to date
you'll see it's passed a number of
bodies in some states it's enacted
and working
in some states it's on its way to being
enacted and my understanding is the
recent action this year is using
identical almost identical or extremely
similar language it's also
uh identical to language that's in the
united states congress currently
so
i can tell you that the folks that i
represent in the major retailer section
of the retail association
plus walmart mr demers will represent
walmart in testimony a little bit later
on have been working on this issue for a
very long time there are folks a lot
smarter than i that have been working on
this language and it's compromise at
this point between all the players
um that that have been mentioned several
times so again it's not new hampshire
language it's not necessarily new or
created uh just in the senate there's a
reason why everything's there
i can tell you
that this
is a priority piece of legislation for
the new hampshire retail association
and the purpose of the bill is not
really addressing
the the average consumer the person that
receives the goods because as you just
discussed there are remedies currently
in place for that
the the
intent of the bill is to address what we
in the retail industry called organized
retail theft
people who steal
from stores your brick and mortar stores
here in new hampshire and elsewhere
in quantities enough to sell and make a
profit
so
to step back a little bit
over the last 20 years the new hampshire
retail association has identified areas
of the new hampshire statutes that we
felt were weak relative to
organized retail theft
and we worked several times with the
folks downstairs in the criminal justice
committee explaining to them the problem
and through their legislative efforts we
think we've got some of the strongest
theft statutes on the books so much so
that we've gotten compliments from folks
in the retail industry in other parts of
of the country
we've given law enforcement tools to
impose uh harsh or stiff penalties we've
given law enforcement tools to go after
the middle man
the fence if you will to use common
parlance and fairly effectively
so we're proud of what we've done with
the legislature and we think this bill
is another piece in that package of
statutes that helps
deter theft
in the state of new hampshire
it's an issue that's
so important to the retail association
that it presents annually a law
enforcement partner of the year
for folks in the law enforcement
community that go above and beyond in
helping us prevent theft
um
that issue that problem has only been
exacerbated by the pandemic and we've
seen
folks
um more frequently our members believe
their items that have been stolen appear
on online marketplaces
uh which is why we're coming to you
today
um
it's the organized retail theft by the
way is uh identified by the us
department of homeland security as a
problem that reaches
the level of 500 billion dollars a year
it is an enterprise it is a criminal
enterprise but it is an enterprise
nonetheless
we think markets should be fair and
equal
typically we prefer the government to
stay out of how we do business
customers should be able to make a
decision who and where they buy items
from
but again this we view as a tool to help
prevent and address a large criminal
enterprise
as i said the the entities
driving this issue in this state and
across the country a large major
retailers
they represent for the retail
association over 100 locations in the
state and tens of thousands of employees
but please don't get the idea to this is
a problem that's unique to large
retailers
if you remember back shortly after the
first of the year there was an incident
that was that received a lot of
attention in the newspapers
a smoke bomb was let off in a jewelry
store in salem in what we're told was a
failed attempt at theft
smash and grab as
senator birdsall mentioned and the idea
is they're going to come in and they're
going to grab a bunch of stuff and leave
if we allow them
free unfettered access to online
marketplaces
they're going to continue to sell and
they're going to continue to steal and
we're hoping to either provide a
deterrent or a way to to address that to
catch them um as i mentioned there is
federal legislation pending
we do prefer a federal solution
and we also all know how quickly
congress acts
um so the map shows you
uh the the vast amount of activity
that's happened to date
in just over three months in this year
alone
um because the states recognize that
they agree with us there's a problem
congress is not acting and and we should
at the state level um
so let me get into some specifics of the
bill um and there's at least one piece
of the attorney general's uh testimony i
wanna i wanna address
um
like to start with page one line ten i
think in my mind this is the
really the key piece that drives this
which is the definition of
uh high volume third party set seller
key pieces here it's a participant in an
online marketplace who is a third-party
seller which is also defined here who
in any continuous 12-month period
during the previous 24 months has
entered into
200 or more discrete sales
of transactions of new
unused consumer products
and an aggregate of a total of five
thousand dollars
so to even
meet the requirements as a seller
under this statute
you have to meet both of those
qualifications with three qualifications
actually new items
uh 200 or more discreet sales in that
short period of time and a total of five
thousand dollars more in gross revenues
um the next requirement in that same
definition is that it requires
um this is applies more to the
marketplace
but the transaction has to be processed
by the online marketplace
so if i'm looking at a classified ad and
i see a used basketball hoop and i go to
the person's home and buy it and i give
them cash for that that doesn't apply no
matter how many basketball hoops that
individual is selling because it's
my transaction cash transaction with him
it's not
the bill when it comes down to it
requires the online marketplace to do
essentially three things
it requires them to collect information
from those people that qualify under
that definition
it requires them to verify that
information
and it requires
that
the marketplace
the bill requires the marketplace to
require of those sellers to provide
a smaller portion of information to the
consumer when they purchase it on the
what it does not do is equally as
important
it does not require that any sensitive
information from the seller
is disclosed to the public
and
page 4 line 22 which is the home address
that the attorney general referenced
is in the section of the bill
referencing
notice to the consumer
that's a privacy issue
if you're a seller on amazon etsy
whatever
and your place of business is your home
address we shouldn't say the state is
requiring you to send out to your
customers your home address if you don't
want to that is a privacy protection
that's built into the bill it's a
the bill also does not require the
marketplace to take any action with law
enforcement i think has already been
discussed
from our perspective the retail industry
if
someone
believes that some merchandise is
showing up on an online marketplace they
believe has been stolen
they can approach they will approach the
marketplace and say hey help us out
we think this is stolen here's why we
think this is our stuff can you look
into it for us
only after information has been gathered
and the retailer collects that
information would they approach law
enforcement say here's our information
and at that point
the normal legal process
uh takes place court order warrant that
sort of thing a normal investigation so
our focus here is twofold
stolen item stolen mass quantities from
retailers um and counterfeit goods which
i'll also address in a little bit
um
so the bill simply says
that if the marketplace meets the
definitions the seller meets the
definitions you collect verify
um
the information and pass it on uh to the
consumer is smaller portion
um i've already discussed the language
that it's that it's mirrored after
um
relative to uh representative bartlett's
question about etsy and these are people
i believe if i understand etsy they
create their own things
the bill also serves as a protection for
the producers as well
there are lots of articles you can find
online about
the manufacturers of the original
article
whose products have been knocked off and
then sold online
products are probably awful they get bad
reviews but the bad reviews are a
reflection on the original manufacturer
right so it hurts their business this
protects them as well in that way to
address uh their counterfeit products so
i think there's protection for sellers
the other protection uh for sellers is
if i'm selling a piece of stolen
merchandise
i've acquired it for nothing my cost of
goods sold and business power parlance
is zero
so anything i sell it for is pure profit
meaning i can sell it for a fairly low
price potentially undercutting somebody
else
some legitimate seller
um
so those are just a couple of examples
of how it protects
the sellers as well
i will wrap up by saying uh in our
opinion again it's a priority bill for
the retail association
um
without this in place
we're pro continuing to allow
the people who are selling stolen
merchandise or counterfeit merchandise
to continue to hide in the shadows
without any deterrence and without any
repercussions
i'm happy to answer questions to the the
best of my ability but i hope i brought
some focus about the intention of the
bill
okay representative bartlett
thank you mr chair um i forgot to ask uh
senator birdsdale what the vote was in
the senate uh the vote out of committee
commerce committee was five to nothing
and it passed on a voice vote in the
senate
thank you for that representative terry
thank you uh so so i have a a senator
outside who's pleaded with me to move
things along in here and i said well
there's only so much i can do
i do have a question
uh and i think um
you might be able to answer it with a
yes or no but don't feel constrained by
what i've been heard in the hall
certainly if you feel like you need to
expand on the answer i believe you've
heard uh
the suggestion made that there be a
mechanism
such that and i'm trying to picture this
that i'm online and uh amazon has a
third party seller and it's a high
volume seller and there's there's maybe
a badge or a label there that says
verified um high volume third party
seller okay
do you believe the members of your
association
would be
amenable if
perhaps not even supportive
of what has been suggested here today to
effectively strengthen
this bill that you overwhelmingly favor
um i cannot answer yes or no
what i can say is you know certainly
we'd pass something along what i do know
is
that because of the
long history of language being developed
you know more than just
2022. you know it's been a few years
and the parties that have signed on to
this i would be hesitant to suggest any
changes to to this bill we're we're
satisfied that for our purposes this
bill will work
thank you
any other questions cnn thank you very
much thank you and i will attend the
subcommittee tomorrow okay
uh chairs michael gaia michael gayes of
my name is michael gea i'm the president
of the new hampshire police association
the new hampshire police association is
an organization that represents all
aspects of law enforcement in the state
from a first-year police officer to a
chief of police
we are here today in support of senate
bill 355.
many of you have probably seen recent
news accounts of smash and grab thefts
at retail establishments
this is a criminal problem that is
occurring in almost every state
it is a significant concern that creates
increased police activity and it creates
a feeling of insecurity for many
businesses
organized thefts really thrive when
there is the opportunity to easily sell
stolen goods
and quite frankly some online platforms
make it way too easy
for them to anonymously unload stolen
property
without the appropriate verification by
these platforms of who the sellers are
criminals utilize the anonymous aspects
of some marketplace platforms
additionally retail stores and their
employees are put in harm's way when
professional thieves confront them to
steal merchandise that is sold online
and i'm certain just about every police
department in new hampshire has received
complaints about counterfeit merchandise
being sold to our residents
many of these illicit products
come from overseas so catching them is
difficult but the simple verification
process
and easy disclosures in sb 355 will have
a detrimental effect on criminal use of
these platforms
we believe passage of sb 355 will help
reduce the amount of stolen property
that is sold online it will help curtail
the smash and grab theft we are seeing
so often and it will make it extremely
difficult for fraudsters to unload
counterfeit goods
because they won't be able to hide
behind an anonymous posting
sp 355 is good for consumers and is good
for legitimate sellers who are up
against these bad actors for these
reasons the new hampshire police
great
xenon thank you very much thank you
uh one more card jim demers representing
walmart
chpa and
pharma
who's chpa chpa is the consumer health
products association so
uh thank you mr chairman um
i'm to sort of get rid of the text or
the speech i was going to give you and
sort of cut to the chase appreciate it
um so let me just say though for the
non-walmart the other two clients of
mine pharma as you've heard earlier is
very concerned about
counterfeit drugs medicines that are now
finding their way
onto some of these marketplaces
they're dangerous they're not real
and it is a growing problem
and the consumer health products
association
represents the over-the-counter
companies
and they're seeing
knock off cough syrups pain medications
even baby formula
that is being
marketed on some of these websites and
it's a growing problem that
those are you know the reasons why those
two groups are supportive of this bill
i
listening today i felt like the
conversation was getting a little bit
more complicated than what the bill
actually does
because if you
if you look at the enforcement provision
which is 358 t4
that doesn't alter any of the criminal
prosecution prosecution aspects
of
any counterfeit or stolen goods
the enforcement strictly
deals with the marketplace if you look
at every shell that's in this bill
the shells apply to
the online marketplace
and so this actually i believe gives our
attorney general
better access to information
because
now we are saying that
the information that these online
marketplaces gather
have to be verified and the ag
during their investigation can ask to
make sure that the verification process
was adhered to
i would think that means prove it
show us that you what you did to verify
uh that the entity
um is legitimate
and
really this takes i think a significant
burden off of
the ag because
we're placing the burden up front
on the marketplace to know who
their
customers are
and if they can't verify
the items that are listed in this bill
it's their responsibility not to put
them on their platform
and that's going to have a gigantic
effect
on making sure that the fraudsters don't
even make their way
into the marketplace
you know the the thing that any criminal
or fraudster enjoys is
being anonymous
and under the current situation
because many of these platforms are not
verifying who they're dealing with
they're receiving fake information
fake names
um fake
tax identification numbers
um they receive their payment from these
platforms
and they're gone in a week
so you can be sure that if somebody a
criminal
has to be verified on who they are
there's a pretty good chance they're not
going to go to the platform
now law enforcement
and the attorney general's office
knows who that person is
so i really think that
this bill goes a long way to
to take the burden off of law
enforcement
it will
really places the burden on the
marketplace to know who their customers
are
to not put them
on the platform because they verified if
they're real or not
um
and and
this doesn't alter any criminal aspect
the prosecution of any fraudster is
going to be handled
whether this bill passes or not exactly
the same way so
i think this bill has significant merit
and as curtis indicated it has passed in
several states
walmart and others think it would be an
important step for new hampshire to join
those states
so we would urge you to support this
measure
representative bartlett
thanks very much mr trump this bill came
over to us as amended by the senate and
curtis had testified that
um
he was hesitant to change any of the
language can you tell me how it was
amended
yes so
um as you heard earlier the significant
stakeholders
walmart the retail merchants association
amazon
took the
federal legislation of which everybody
has signed off on
uh and converted that into this bill
so this the bill we had before was not
identical to what the federal bill is
that everybody
has been working to try to get past in
washington so
this model this bill that you have
before you is completely modeled after
the federal bill of which
with the exception of one state that's
what all the states are doing as well
i mean i think you did hear
from from curtis that everyone's
preference would be
to deal with this at the federal level
this bill has been hanging around and
it's not on anyone's high agenda in
washington
so i think there's just this growing
feeling that it's time to try to do
something if washington's not going to
okay so this sorry
for the question
so this bill is the federal bill that is
correct
would those changes have been in the
exemptions of what is a high volume
everything yes the definitions are
exactly what's in i'm saying the one
state that's different
oh um sorry
i think i hope that's on arkansas where
walmart's located it is arkansas okay
we'll get arkansas okay
representative
thank you mr chairman um this may be a
different type of problem um that
doesn't come under this bill i'm not
sure but i've seen
several uh advertisements online for
example i saw one
with uh honda
uh generators and they had a whole bunch
of honda generators in the picture and
they were saying
over stock we're selling these for 50
bucks i saw the same thing on
uh steel products chainsaws leaf blowers
is that come under this i looked at that
and said this is just a scam um because
they were so underpriced so if those
products are being sold by the actual
manufacturer
they're not under this if those products
are being sold through one of these
online marketplaces like amazon or
walmart site
then they would fall under the same
requirements of having to
supply the information that's listed
here and then be verified
okay
they understand the key element there if
you got an email from somebody
this unless it's unless it was one of
these
online marketeers
then it would not qual this this
legislation won't help that's true but i
mean i i don't really know i didn't look
into it because i just thought it was a
scam and it probably was it probably was
but
i'll have to look into it more carefully
thank you
okay representative johnson
hi thank you for taking my question
um
would this apply to like the facebook
marketplace uh craigslist things like
that because they really don't
you know people just post stuff on there
and for sale and you can pay through
paypal or whatever
would that apply to these
platforms it actually does not apply if
they are
like an online classified ad so if the
transaction is not being facilitated by
the platform but they're merely
connecting you with the seller
to negotiate your deal like a newspaper
ad would do they are not included in
this bill
i think the key element is where's the
who's got the money so if you're
handing the money to that directly to
that person
for the product and they're shipping it
to you they would be exempt from this
correct
okay
you can't
i know i'm responsible evidently your
name's on yours
representative
if you wanted to would you believe sure
you can go ahead
thank you mr chair and thank you for
your testimony i hope what would you
believe
um
a lot of the
the products that were used to be
prescription products are now
over the counter
and i buy a lot of them through amazon
because they're way lot cheaper
and the consumer me has the last
responsibility i look at the packaging i
look at the bottles i look at the seals
i look at the product itself to make
sure this is virtually the same thing
that i've been buying for
whatever period would you believe
yes i i would believe but i will tell
you that there are a lot of people that
receive those
counterfeit products in packaging that
they think it's the real product and i'm
you may be more vigilant than others but
there are a lot of people
who think it's sold online it's got to
be
you know the real item and it's not
well would you believe okay that's
enough thank you very much
yes and with that we'll close the public
hearing thank you mr chairman but
according to consumer reports uh this
month
amazon is the most expensive when it
comes to pharmaceuticals
so
able to take that
is that would you believe all right we
will move quickly into the next bill i
would say on this bill 355 there were 21
in support two opposed
and
senator burchell and bruce berkey was in
you
if you didn't save all these bills for
the end to get out of your committee
they wouldn't have all shown up at the
end and might give it exactly you know
i'm glad we passed that one over for
nothing's easy in the hell's commerce
committee as you know that's why we love
you guys
okay we'll open the public hearing on
senate bill 324
and uh not that i have a card from you
but that's okay
thank you i know who you are i will fill
one out mr chair thank you
good morning mr chair and the entire
committee
it's so nice to be back here again
i'm
for the record my name is harold french
and i am senator from district 7. i am
here to present to you today senate bill
324.
so there's a little history with this
bill
when
i sat in commerce every time
in the house every time we got a bill to
address this i said no
two years in the house i said no
as chair of commerce in the senate
every time something like this would
come through i would say no
this year
i was listening to these people and i
realized this problem's not going to go
away so i
had drafted senate bill 324 and the
original bill
addressed
homeowners associations
it addressed condos
and it in an addressed um
oh
co-ops
now when that bill came out it was the
bill that would
solve this problem it set up a state
board to overview disputes
it also brought out about 480 people
against the bill
and the women behind me
for it
so
in other words it didn't go over too
well shall we say
so senator bradley using his wisdom
said let's address what we can address
now
that will make a difference and
therefore we have the bill that you have
this bill
works on condo associations and
homeowners associations
and uh the co-ops home homeowner co-ops
and this bill
just because there's so many disputes
within these condo associations and
homeowners associations are these
co-ops
this bill
requires these groups to have a dispute
resolution board
within their own unit
it's nothing run by the state which is
probably the way to do it
except it's not going to pass and no one
likes it except me and the people behind
me
so i would like you to listen to what
these people have to say about it
why they need it
and why you shouldn't listen to your
chairman when he tries to kill this
so thank you very much mr chair
it's always a pleasure to see you too
and how did it come out of the senate
committee
this one
came out uh fairly well actually uh
looking here
why do you ask these questions
you know by now
it came out uh
just say you'll get back to her later
thank you i'll get back to you later but
if you look at the bill docket sheet
it'll be on there i just can't read it
it's too small all right representative
burroughs
yeah
thank you for taking my question senator
over here um one concern i have is the
makeup of the resolution board
because
with the exception of the person
appointed by the bar
it's it's it's either the speaker of the
house or the governor which means that
the majority party could have
the entire basically the entire board
and and um you know let's just say that
it's governor sherman
you're seeing that might be a problem to
some people that governor sherman could
appoint all these people and the speaker
of the house so that's my concern that
the majority party is going to control
that
evidently he's easy
any other questions
from the community members
so i have one question for you i'll get
you i'll get them but i have a question
for you yes
did anybody consider that shouldn't we
just
require that any new condos a new
homeowner association anything going
forward any
change in their bylaws it should have a
statement in there about what exactly is
the grievance procedure of that
particular association
mr chair you know as well as i do
people don't read those
i know and this was my argument the same
is yours all along
for
six seven years i had the same argument
do your homework
but it doesn't work
so this would settle it
okay
i'm telling you don't listen to him
thank you
i sit here all day i don't get to ask
any questions
uh thank you for your testimony senator
french um
i think i was on the
condo commission with you when we
talked about the idea for this bill
we also talked about sunsetting that
commission
which i think has been in place 14 or 15
years
would you be amenable to putting a
sunset in this i would
thank you
okay
representative burroughs you have
another question or
represented van hauten
yeah
the way you phrased that another
question another well you're own s1
technically
i'll make it quick
um i don't understand um
item 22 to 23 in the event of a dispute
between an association of between a
homeowner and the association the
resolution shall favor the property
owner i don't understand that why is
page four i'm sorry i should have said
paid for you you don't have the new
pages
the new and improved so that was the
original okay okay
that was the that's all been done
okay my bad thank you that was fine
all right represent van halen you're all
right now you want to give a question
okay i do have a quick question um isn't
this essentially what exists now if i
have a dispute don't i go to the board
now and if they say no connie you're
crazy i could not go i could go to court
as well this is a
i believe this will create a new board
that just handles disputes
within the communities
thank you i didn't thank you for taking
my question should that be more
specified here
that it's a
separate dispute board as opposed to the
board of directors
that would
it's open
these are all conversations these can be
changed and
and
made better
with
your your thoughts
thank you
we thank you very much no i thank you
who
has been working on this issue for many
many years
not 15.
we put this together in
we had six months before the o'brien
administration removed everybody who was
on it except
one who got sidelined
uh
we have had a lot of problem this uh
representative me on
grafton 13 city of lebanon
and also on
for a lot more than 15 years
chair of president of my homeowners
association
by
popular demand because they couldn't
find anybody to replace me when i tried
to retire the first time
it's a small homeowners association
on
we
um
the problem
that we have with these
associations
uh condominium one and the homeowners
association one which doesn't
occur with the manufactured housing
parks there are already two
uh
bodies that take very good care of those
in just about every situation that you
can can create
the first one was created by
representative senator judge
gordon
who currently chairs
the
two small
homeowners association
uh representative
abramson forgot to say he wanted to add
an extra member
to to us so that we wouldn't have all of
these perpetual quorum problems the
senate having
removed someone and made us for people
but
um
the
um the housing
uh the manufactured housing parks are
are on
overseen
by the manufactured housing board
does a very good job of this uh
and
most of the co-op manufactured housing
parks the tenant-owned ones
on
are
on i think all of them probably
have
guidance from the community loan fund
for the duration of their lives
so um and that guidance has a lot it's
very heavily concentrated i think in
later years in making sure that
boards properly represent
the
the owners
and that there is a
democratically elected board
and that people know what's going on
that doesn't
hasn't worked everywhere it didn't work
in one place and that was the genesis of
the opposition
uh to this bill but the opposition to
the to the original bill
uh was aggravated by the fact that
on
added to the bill were a lot of
stipulations for homeowner associations
the first of which in my mind is
something that no homeowner association
board and most of its membership
would think was feasible at all
that is that every board
see
every board rotate the entire membership
of the association
through the board
in two-year terms
on
almost all
partly or mostly second homeowners
they aren't around
on
in my small association we have a number
of people who are physically or mentally
or both incapable
of doing that work
on and
won't
and several others that are very
very heavy workers
we have a lot of hospital people
on and
they find it very difficult
uh
to participate
so um
so there were a number of other
stipulations which a number of
homeownerizations associations because
they vary a lot would find quite
difficult
and a lot of people came out to oppose
the bill
on
the commission got a chance to look at
it for i think it was 15 minutes while
we were discussing at the same time
and it was
seven pages long something like that
so
and we
we only discussed the possibility of
amending it in the house once it came
over
so
on i am here
to ask you to itles bill
so that we can can uh start with a clean
slate again next term
on this
and
the chair doesn't like this idea much
but the biggest problem we have with the
condominium and the homeowner
associations is when
the board
with or without the property manager
goes bad
will not allow the owners to see the
financial documents will not allow the
owners to vote
uh there are a fair number of boards
that are self-perpetuating
uh over the years and a number of these
places
run into major financial problems
because of this kind of behavior too
because they aren't properly doing
maintenance
and
they get a reputation
around town for
for
discriminatory behavior
and um the property values go down
and then people are faced with
do i sell
i want to get out of here
at
a bargain price to somebody who doesn't
know what's going on
a lot i've had people
uh one couple it was in my association
that
a drunkard moved in next door that was
very difficult for them they waited to
sell until he had died
because they were honest and they didn't
something that we couldn't do anything
about but
um
but
on
or do or are they trapped some people
walk away from these associations they
just
uh crumble half the people have walked
away
because
they
they can afford to do it but a lot of
other people move into these places
as retirees
having calculated exactly how much they
can afford
to pay
for their housing for the rest of their
life and can't afford to move away
so
we do need something this is not it this
is what we are doing now
except that it adds an extra step which
is
for the people that
have decided that the board is doing
wrong
to ask for a meeting with that board and
have the board tell them they don't care
because they've already been doing that
and then they can after that they can go
to the superior court which is the only
place they can go now
and that takes at least two years of
waiting and
i'm not talking about pandemic time i'm
talking about pre-pandemic
and it used to be 20 000 it's probably
more than that now
to get yourself through this
so it it very rarely happens things just
crumble or people
or they sell to we've had a couple of
people come to us because
they'd bought something they thought was
great and then it wasn't
so
also
the homeowners associations there is no
definition in the rsas of a homeowners
association
so you need to provide one if you pass
this
and um that's all i had to say and i'm
sorry it took a bit more than two
minutes
no problem thank you very much for your
testimony uh representative
thank you and welcome to commerce uh
representative um did you when you read
this or when you i'm sure you followed
this i know that you've been involved in
this very heavily for quite a while
um do you read this as
establishing a separate dispute board or
having the person who has a dispute
going to the existing condo board or
homeowner's association this does not
this talks about the boar governing
board of the condominium or the
homeowners association or the tenants
association nah they it actually they
aren't tenants
they're owners in the manufactured
housing parks that are co-ops
but
um
if they own it they aren't tenants
thank you but anyway
um
so
on it
it's the existing board
that is supposed to hear the case about
why there is a problem with the existing
board
follow it please for the question may
inquire thank you
um the senator who introduced this
indicated that there is a possibility of
making change do you think that if it
were a dispute board as opposed to the
board of directors of the association
that that would strengthen the spill
we have a lot of smaller homeowner
associations and co and condo
associations i know one that's only four
on you can't put fit two boards into
those places but
uh and it's it's difficult i mean you're
talking about volunteers
doing what
town and city governments do
and smaller towns have problems getting
volunteers to be clerk and things like
that on
so do
and but they have the new hampshire
municipal association to help them out
uh these associations don't have anybody
above them to help them out
thank you
except for the manufactured housing
board and
the community loan fund
we thank you very much for coming in
thank you uh we have one more uh
representative
gargiulo
uh in support of the bill
uh and he says he's representing himself
and
condo associate cai
the community association
good afternoon mr chairman and the
committee i'm happy to be before you
today my name is lou gargiulo i reside
in hampton falls new hampshire and i'm
the ceo and founder of great north
property management in exeter new
hampshire my firm is responsible for the
management of more than 25 000
condominium and homeowners association
units
that
house approximately 75 000 people i am
also a member of the community
association legislative action committee
for those of you who don't know what cai
is a community association institute is
a public interest group nationally that
works for the betterment of unit owners
in condominium and homeowners
associations across the country
i'm here today to voice my support and
the support of the cai legislative
action committee for the revised
senate bill 324.
in my opinion the bill as originally
proposed was a solution in search of a
problem that doesn't really exist to any
great degree
that would warrant creating another
government board and more bureaucracy
it's important to note
i regress to say there are 265 thousand
approximately residents who live in
condominiums in new hampshire in
approximately 107 000 homes in 2200
associations
please
take note i'm speaking in favor of it
representative almi is speaking against
it
that tells you the extent of the problem
there is a very limited problem
the amended bill provides additional
protection for unit owners if there is a
runaway board a runaway board president
who refuses to meet with the unit owner
who has an issue this bill compels them
to do it
if they fail to do it then this gives
that unit owner if necessary additional
evidence to bring before a superior
court judge to say we have exhausted
every effort and the association refuses
to meet with us i think this is a
reasonable compromise the unit owner
has to be responded to with a meeting
within 30 days and the board has to be
responded respond to them in 30 days so
it gives a clear trail for the unit
owner if in fact they're being abused
if the parties don't come to a mutually
acceptable resolution they can still
bring the issue
before a court of competent jurisdiction
i believe the
amended bill is a reasonable compromise
that will move the process of belong if
something does exist without the state's
interference or expense
keep in mind if there was as proposed
before
a board created people from all over the
state would have to come they would have
to pay a fee
either side in that dispute would end up
appealing it to the superior court and
it would cost double the amount of money
this provides
local control over a locally uh elected
board and provides the unit owner a
relief if they feel they're being abused
and provides the material of that relief
if the matter has to be taken
for it i ask you to find this bill
good to legislate and move it forward to
the entire house thank you
great thank you any questions from the
committee uh representative van halen
i'd just like to follow up in my earlier
questioning uh is it your interpretation
that there would be a separate dispute
board separate from the board of
directors to whom someone would bring a
concern no
that's not how the language is written
in the board and on that point i agree
with representative elmi uh there are
not huge some of these associations in
new hampshire are very small and to
create an additional board would be a
cumbersome issue and i don't see any
need i think though this board forces
the association if for some reason a
board member or any board refuses to
meet this compels them to do it and it
will be in the governing documents of
the association that they have to amend
their bylaws accordingly
follow a place follow-up question just
the same the same line of questioning
that i've asked the earlier
people who have testified
so in essence with this bill and i
should clarify i am a condominium owner
and occupant and i have served on boards
in other states
um but i'm not speaking for myself i'm
speaking about the experiences that i've
seen
based upon the idea that the complainant
would go to the condominium board of i'm
using condominium but it's i know it's
more extensive
the claimant the complainant would go to
the condominium board that currently
exists
that that currently
if if i have a concern
and i i don't get any kind of recourse
from the condominium board of directors
and i go to them they're the same people
that i have a complaint against can i
expect to get a resolution that's fair
and just i think you can i think most
people on boards are there for the right
reasons i think there are very remote
situations where that may not be the
case i deal with many boards i serve on
boards myself and i think in most cases
they will i
have heard of cases where a board
refuses to meet and they say we're just
not doing it and i think this bill
corrects that issue because if they
don't meet they're violating
both the letter and the spirit of the
law and i think that puts them in a very
difficult position if the unit owner
decides to bring it to the superior
court so i think it serves a significant
purpose without creating more laws and
more infrastructure for people to pay
more money to go to so i think this is a
relief that wasn't there that will be
helpful thank you
great thank you very much thank you uh
so i have uh
that looks uh familiar to me uh bonnie
galore's and
louise
ripcon
shouldn't remember your name already but
i guess something nobody can spell my
name that's what the good spot is today
okay
so uh so you got one of you wrote five
minutes the other one bites so hopefully
you'll you get that
we we have heard this issue many many
times before in this committee this
obviously is a new version a new
solution so i guess if you can focus on
why this one is
why this one is so great that would be
good
good afternoon gentlemen
as you know my name is bonnie gories and
i'm here today representing myself
louise wrightout and john murphy from
bfu crossing cooperative in allenstown
and he could not be here with us today
as you know we are in favor of sb 324 we
need a mechanism within each cooperative
to handle complaints relative to the
bylaw violations whether the violations
are tenants of the cooperative or
members of the board
if a resolution cannot be reached at the
cooperative level the tenant still has
the ability to challenge the issue at
the superior court in our community and
many others complaints are not addressed
by the boards
leaving we as residents without a voice
the bill is a step in the right
direction to protect our rights and
interests of the tenants in all resident
owned communities
thank you
louise i was a model of brevity thank
you
that was very brief thank you
go ahead
hi my name is louise rideout and
i live at bearview crossing cooperative
in allenstown
and you're right the last time was a lot
a lot of testimony this time the revised
edition i understand that
the concern of not having a separate
board
but we really don't want it to be where
we're so
like controlled by everything it should
be something that responsible adults can
take care of but unfortunately that
doesn't always happen
so some type of a guideline is is very
good and it's important because
you know you know you might have a board
that you can work with or you might have
a board that you can't work with like
two months ago one of them i think it
was two months ago at a meeting one of
our zoom meetings um the community loan
fund
uh tech representative alan blake he's
he addressed the meeting by saying
five people
which we have five members of the board
can't run the park
so
in that regards you have to understand
that's happened sometimes
so to have this in place for us if we
need it it's important it's not
frivolous it's you know it's important
to have a separate resolution board
would be nice but if we can't do that
we're adults we're homeowners or adults
we should be able to
you know get things done
one thing i would really like to
address is that
this bill as it states about the bylaws
our when we became a co-op three years
ago
in 2019
we use the templates of the community
loan fund
we were
it was kind of like this is what would
work best for you and at some point
we tried to adopt different bylaws which
there was a lot of opposition against
bylaws that would probably better suit
our own community
so that didn't help a little bit the one
thing that i would hope that this would
address too is that you wouldn't have
third-party entities like
community loan fund or anybody else that
would want to
you know sway
the board
and have the board maybe um
adopt what they want instead of what is
best for the community
and when that happens it really causes a
lot of problems for the homeowners
because now you have a board that could
be influenced by outside people
telling them that you know you should do
it this way you should do it that way
you know get rid of this person get rid
of that person instead of us being able
to have this so this is really something
that can protect people
who are being targeted and you know
having the board
some boards in place being swayed by
outside parties which i don't think
should be it should be right in within
our own community and our own we should
be adults and be able to handle it
without any interference from any other
sources
i thank you for listening
i just i i want to just say something
about what you just said and louise is
that louise is absolutely right
um
we don't need anybody to sway the board
that that that's in place right now
you have people on the board who might
not like louise who might not like me
and we have to bring something up to
them we're not going to get anything do
you know what i'm trying to say yep we
we had um for instance last last year we
had someone sitting on the board that
was not following the bylaws and tried
to
take five people out off the membership
and then throw them out of the park
that
that that was not right they did not
follow the bylaws the people that were
in place on that board did absolutely
nothing a technical adviser didn't do
anything to advise him that what they
were doing was incorrect
so consequently these we had five
tenants that were
beside himself because he said well
where are we going to go we own this
house now we're going to get evicted
because i've got a moped sitting on my
lawn
do you know what i'm trying to say so we
we need protection ourselves
you know
not everybody's personality matches
not everybody's going to agree with
everybody else but when you have a board
in place
that has issues with people in the park
you're not going to you're going not
going to get fair decision from them
representative greeson has a question
thank you mr chair and thank you ladies
for for coming for us again you are in
support of this bill yes sir okay
uh
as i read this there is nothing to
protect
the owner
from retribution for having sued
if it goes to that so they can't get
satisfaction at the
at the board level at the park or the
condo association they have to sue
but there's nothing to protect them
against retribution against this
against the owner
even if it's if it's satisfactory
regardless of the outcome of that suit
for or against
uh would you be uh
amenable to
something that would specif specify
protection against retribution i would
yes i would too in fact we need that
probably more so yeah no kidding right
representative painting big targets on
yourself
someone said that to me when i walked
can i just share something i'm sorry to
interrupt when i bought this home
in 2018 it wasn't a co-op then heinz
owned it holiday acres
and when i bought it
i have four children and three
grandchildren
and my youngest son who's in the
hospital right now he was participating
to help me in the process and i tried to
teach him a little bit about the process
of home i owned homes before mass but
this was a different situation he was
old enough to learn my two young
grandchildren love coming up there and i
am a responsible homeowner i you know
maintain my property i care about my
community i care about my neighbors and
right now the bull's-eye on my back is
so big that i feel like
you know this is something it's better
than nothing that's right but i do like
the fact um representative greeson that
you would like to see about including
some type of um
retribution yeah yeah thank you very
much i appreciate that thank you for
bringing that up because thank you that
and just to mirror what she said
i've only lived here for a year and a
half
um
i took all the money that the va gave me
after fighting to make my husband a
service-related disability i left my
family and friends behind came up here
to live a nice peaceful life
let me tell you when i have to keep my
curtains closed during the day and i
have to buy security cameras because my
people in my park are targeting me
because people on the
we'll just leave it like that but i'm
okay thank you very much i have a yeah
oh representative has a question i'm
sorry thank you mr chair um thank you
for taking my question can you go to
superior court now
no we don't have any recourse right now
we can talk offline but their issue was
what the way the transaction occurred
because i just would would you believe
i've been to superior court with condo
owners who have been targeted
it does happen
often yes it does often
and um we went to superior court
to challenge the board
and uh they won but they had to spend
thousands of dollars
you know what and and i can understand
that but in some in some instances
like for louise and myself who are
targeted again um
to me it would be beneficial because
somebody has to stand up for what's
right
but they also also it would cause a
burden if you are bringing you know to
go to superior court if you're bringing
anything against the board in your co-op
it would eventually cost money and
and
it would teach people like hey you got
to do the right thing and be ethical but
on the other hand
you know my neighbors we're not we're
not wealthy people we're all like
regular people but but there has to be
some accountability i totally agree with
accountability because if you don't have
any
and people the boards run wrong they do
and
the issues that we have
of people
running rogue and
they're very it's very right now you're
right about the money even if you go
forward we're missing so much money
anyway so if you go forward i mean it it
might actually make people accountable
thank you very much for sharing thank
you thank you i appreciate that yeah
like what we said we're missing almost
we're missing a lot of money anyway
great well thank you very much ladies
sir thank you okay
i got two more cards left uh silvia
young
uh
representing rm hv co-op inc and
tenement
manufactured housing in guilford new
hampshire
and i assume uh you're deborah
richardson
all right perfect to the two of you
again wrap it up for us
hopefully it'll be less than 10 minutes
okay
you have to turn your that little yep
perfect i just want to say that this
bill i mean i haven't lived in a co-op
i've always owned my own property so
when we moved here my husband and i
he wasn't feeling good so we figured
this would be a nice community to live
in but what i'm finding out and i was on
the board for only eight months because
i was the first person
to be different from the man that's been
running it for 11 years
and in the eight months
every month
i had issues because he would stand
outside because he wasn't on the board
and tell everybody to come in and
complain to us about what we were doing
wrong
i've never been on a board before and i
said that right off the bat that i knew
what this i'm willing to learn
but it was constant
every month and finally after every
eight months they put a petition on me
because and my whole board
that uh they wanted us off the board
because we weren't doing things their
way
now as of this day
pretty much four of them are still on
the board
as and this was three years ago
so they're all back on the board what
they want but what i'm saying is
the our board anyway
is uh if i like you you can do this but
if you i don't like you it can be the
same thing as my friend and you're not
gonna do it
and it's constant constant
you know i mean
the one of the man that i talk about a
lot of times he asks for a lot of our
issues with our people in the park
you know with neighborly issues because
he he tells one neighbor one thing he
tells the other neighbor to sing you
know a different thing and so that
causes conflict
from neighbor to neighbor i'm just
saying i think
that the board needs more accountability
because they don't follow the bylaws or
our rules they they make up their own
they feel
that that's and half of them don't know
what the bylaws and rules are so they
don't even read them before they go in
so i think this will help if they they
need accountability and we need be able
to have a voice
because you go to them and they just
shrug it off like you're just i mean
we've been my husband and i
anybody that speaks with us is targeted
they won't talk to them
i've had a new neighbor that moved in
across the street
they will not associate because they
they talk to my husband and i because
they call us the troublemakers because
we did put up we started with um karen
susan and senator french
and i mean so we are the biggest
troublemakers in the park because we
went ahead
and silvia because she she made
headlines in our little paper so she's a
big target
okay so thank you very much but i i
approve i wish this bill would go
through some kind of help for us great
thank you
i agree everything debbie said was true
the only thing i have to add is that
we did try to get a lawyer
because of all the
conflicts in that
and they didn't want any part of us
and i think it's because of this
gentleman this he's not a gentleman
this person that's causing the truth
he's been a president and everything
else for ye 11 years
and
sadly he's my neighbor
so that doesn't tell that matters but
what i want to say is we do need help
someplace we couldn't get it from work
we couldn't get it from lawyers we
didn't know where to turn
until we called
harold for french and karen
and that's where we got started
to get some help but it's it's a shame
that you
live in a place that you have four or
five people dominating everything
they want lately
this last this existing board
will not
tell you anything
and they they
didn't have meetings for four months in
a row
and
one one said to me and from another
board
if you don't like it leave
which is very nice
and
she was the same as
this fellow on the board that just gives
you trouble after trouble
he doesn't like me
because i will answer him back
and
most people are afraid to answer him
and so naturally being neighbors we have
conflicts
so the other day i get a phone call and
it's for the president of the board
telling me
if i don't stop
harassing a lot of people
i didn't know i knew that many people
but he uh
she said you will be disciplined
and you will be
warned i warn you right now
you will be losing your membership
so
i'm not afraid of it because
i have gotten a hold of the
local paper
and they will be hearing about this
and she's
the the writer isn't agree with me
to have another article in the paper
and the president of our board
absolutely will
be mad as heck because
she left the board
the same day the first
article came out
so i mean what does that say you know
but another thing we don't trust this
man at all as far as our money goes
with the park
he is charging 20 to 25
for every contract he
makes so that's costing us the members
more money
but he denies well he's a perpetual liar
anyways
and he denies everything
so you can't win with them and
i just we need help that's what we need
we thank you for coming here and sharing
your stories it's very helpful but uh we
do have a question representative this
is really quick would you believe that
you said that you're troublemakers you
are a good kind of trouble
thank you
okay
uh having no more cards uh we had uh two
people in support
senator carson and senator reagan and
three people in opposition
uh curtis holland
uh jason
osborne and paul worswitz and with that
i will close the
you
well i'm just
since i spent
what do you think the mood is on that uh
marketplace
oh that'll be interesting i'm not sure
yeah sure i'm not sure
republicans
okay
yes
that's right around the corner
oh
it's not your fault it's just that
um
bye
yep
okay
oh
is
okay
so sorry about the delay
all right so we'll open up the public
hearing uh senate bill 286
establishing an association health plan
pilot program
good morning senator
afternoon senator uh good afternoon mr
chair members of the committee i am uh
denise rashardi the senator for district
nine
and i uh before i
read what i prepared
um one of the things that was really
just pulled michael a little closer oh
one of the things that was concerning me
is our
high health care premiums that we all
pay
i wanted to come up with a strategy that
could help all the people in new
hampshire
and
it's a little
difficult trying to go
straight forwards with the department of
insurance so i opted to do a pilot to
give it a a good run so i'll read for
you what i prepared
senate bill 286 would direct the
department of insurance to set up a
pilot program for the establishment of
association health plans the high cost
of health insurance is a burden for
families across the country and the new
hampshire and new hampshire
unfortunately we face some of the
highest
health insurance premiums in the nation
these high costs not only hurt our
families but make it harder for new
hampshire companies to attract employees
and help our state's economy thrive
we have tried top-down washington
solutions to make health care more
affordable they don't work
we need to bring more choice and more
competition to our health insurance
marketplace
and
a
hps are one way to do that health
insurance works by pooling risk but when
your pool is too shallow it's hard to
spread that risk affordably
we have spread the risk through large
health insurance companies or some large
companies have enough employees to
self-insure
in fact that's what the state of new
hampshire does hiring an insurance
company to administer the plan but
taking on the risk of paying health
insurance claims itself
small and medium-sized companies and the
self-employed don't have that option
if we could give it to them
you know it would be wonderful what if
we allowed small companies to pull
together to share that risk
associated health plans could lower
annual premiums up to 4 000 in small
group markets and possibly as much as 10
000 in the individual market
let's find out if this kind of
innovation can work in new hampshire
sb 286 would set up a pilot program of
up to 1 000 participants based on
profession
line of business or geographic region
it would be open to any eligible person
regardless of age or health history
the department of insurance would report
annually on the pilot's program's
progress and the pilot would expire in
2025 leaving it to future legislators
whether this program should be extended
or expanded
the committee amendment ensures that
those taking part in the pilot will
continue to receive the highest quality
of care mandated in our statute
sb 286 received unanimous support from
the senate health and human services
committee and pass the senate on the
consent calendar
i ask for your support for this bill
which will add some innovation to new
okay representative van halen thank you
thank you for coming um i would just
like to to ask you for a definition at
least as used here of association health
plans that's a term i'm not familiar
with okay so association health keep
sure you're close to the mic because
we're we actually okay sorry
i always think i'm so loud
um
for example
let's just say all the real estate
agencies wanted to pull together and
become their own insurance it would
offset their costs for their
uh employees because they were able to
pull together
you could do it for
any business could pull together that's
like minded
and
i think it would be a really great way
it's a test it's a pilot so we see if it
works if it works it could save a lot of
money and really help people out
thank you
other questions from the committee
representative johnson
thank you senator for coming today with
this bill
what would the cost be
for the state
on
to get this up or is it just basically
letting them kind of
run it themselves they presented and
they are in agreement to do this as a
pilot and they are there's no additional
cost they're just going to participate
um
if it were to be successful and we would
be able to make it permanent i'm sure
there would maybe be some additional
representative bartlett thank you mr
chair um where would the actuarial
tables be coming
from to um set this up and would all
comers
be have to be accepted so regardless of
um
physical condition thank you for the
question um
everything is going to be under the
department of insurance
uh they've agreed to do this pilot and
it will not exclude anyone we have those
mandates set up in new hampshire and we
are not going to
change that so regardless of health or
age
representative burroughs
thank you for taking my question quick
question i know it's limited to a
thousand participants is there a minimum
number of people in each association
for the health pla in the let's say
there's a group i mean a realtors uh a
subgroup or realtor yes just for the
pilot they'll be they're going to put
out um to
see who would be interested in
participating in the pilot should you
pass this bill
and
i believe there will be three different
groups so
it'll be limited
as a pilot but i plan and hope to get
behind it and make sure it's a success
so that we can open this opportunity for
everyone in new hampshire thank you
um
so
i i realize you're
a freshman senator so you're maybe not
been around or known a lot of health
insurance stuff
and i'm unfortunately been around too
long
and so the first question is is this
having this thousand dollar limit is
actually
unbelievable because it's usually their
statute i think it's still i don't know
did we repeal
our statues we you had to have a minimum
of three thousand people to be
uh so so where did where did the
thousand and come from where did you get
this i may be a freshman but i do my
homework okay and where did you get this
from i i
worked with the department of insurance
to craft this for this pilot
and um everybody was on board with this
this is a pilot this is not you know
etched in stone the department is
neutral
well they're neutral but i went i didn't
just arbitrarily put this in without
having discussions because if i had it
my way it wouldn't be a pilot it would
be permanent
so if if the plans have to comply with
all our current state regulations
all our mandates
all our requirements
why would the premium be less
you're pooling
you're pulling people together in a
larger group and you're letting them do
this
independently of what we currently do
yeah that's the part i don't get the
independent part because if all the
mandates in here are the exact same
mandates
that all small employers have to come
you know have to you know when they get
insurance
isn't when we have right now harvard and
anthem
isn't they just a very large
associated health plan because they just
have all these you know more than one
thousand they have a bunch of thousands
of people but that they're you're
complying with the same they're
complying with the exact same
regulations that you want to comply with
well i think the difference is that
when you have
you're still going to have an insurance
overseer be it blue cross or what have
you mentioned you are now
i'm going to go back to real estate
agents how many are there in this state
that could band together to reduce their
costs
and then come under the umbrella of one
of the larger companies
so
this is not an original idea and
what the number one reason just because
i always think it's important before
someone leaves a committee why where we
are
is that is a phrase called adverse
selection
and the adverse selection is that
someone is going to try to create a
group that theoretically everybody in
that group is going to be young and
healthy and so therefore that is the way
they'll make the premiums lower
but if you to take an association like
you're describing let's say realtors
we actually do we have two we have a
banker's association and uh
that they had an organization and we
exempted them and we permit but we do
have that 3000 person requirement
because we want to make sure they stay
solvent
and
at the end of the day
you're
you you haven't there's nothing in this
that's going to be particularly
attractive and they're still going to
have to pay for all those associated
costs for that entity whatever it is
whether it's the
retail merchants association or a new
hampshire hospitality association
that if they want to try to do this
they have to still
theoretically going to pay the same
premium as everybody else
well i had a lot of support for this and
again it's a pilot and sometimes the
pilot you have to get the kinks worked
out and i do realize the history of
trying to improve the health care costs
for the granite staters and it has not
been successful
but we have to keep trying we have to
keep doing something about it we can't
leave it like it is so i'd ask for your
consideration to try the pilot it is
just that it's a test
and how long does the pilot last for
until 2025
and then it theoretically could expire
correct it depends on if it succeeds
or it fails
got it
representative greeson
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for uh for introducing this uh
at the end of the sunset
how do those people maintain their
health care coverage at that point
assuming assuming for some reason that
the pilot program failed because
sometimes
we're in working with the department of
insurance we're going to make allowances
and we're going to get the those type of
wrinkles taken out
when the people who decide they want to
participate come forward we'll be
working with them on that
thank you
great thank you very much thank you
uh chair will call on tyler brennan the
name of your insurance department
otherwise the dry cleaner that gets the
thank you i will do my best and uh
um so tyler brandon life and health
director of the insurance department and
chairman hunt actually did point out a
number of things i was going to my
testimony um we are neutral on the on
the bill and a lot of what i'd say about
this bill as it relates to hps i would
also say about some about the other bill
student bill 160 that relates to me was
they both are based on this concept that
employers could come together and
negotiate a better premium and we are
talking about mostly small employers
there was the example of sort of sole
proprietors and that raises kind of some
a number of other related issues
but just to kind of touch base on what
exists now for the small group market is
you've got what is essentially a kind of
a modified community rating type
approach so insurers can adjust the
premiums up to three to one based on the
age of the people who are covered and
that's a lot i mean three times the
premium can change your premium from
year to year quite a bit if you're a
small employer and one of your younger
employees leaves and you hire somebody
who's older all of a sudden your average
premium is quite a bit higher we've had
to field a number of questions from
employers who were surprised how much
their premiums went up whereas the
reality was their underlying sort of mix
of employees did change
one of the things that is exists both in
state and federal laws though are these
protections that you're all familiar
with doing away with pre-existing
conditions doing way with consideration
of health status and that's going to be
one of the limitations when you're
trying to allow employers to come
together and negotiate a better premium
than what they're used to doing even if
you could get around kind of those
federal
regulations you do introduce that
concept of risk selection
and
so
one of the other realities is that our
health insurance premiums the amounts we
paid are carriers 80 between 85 and 92
percent of those premiums go out in the
form of medical claims costs
that means if you're looking for a 20
savings on the premiums
there's got to be something very
different about the insurance product
you're buying in order to get there
either you've got to reduce coverage or
you've got to increase massively
increased cost sharing or you've got to
somehow cherry pick and that's one of
the concerns obviously from the market
point of view
so the question about a pilot program
like this is is well what is the
insurance department going to do in
developing a pilot program that's going
to give those employers something that
the carriers are not giving them now i
like to remind people that it's their
business it's the insurance companies
business to develop products that people
want to buy or employers want to buy at
a competitive price point so somehow
we've got to demand something from the
carriers that they haven't been offering
that would reduce premiums something
significantly different
generally when employers come together
when people come together and
collectively buy they're less likely to
want to reduce benefits they're more
likely to want to actually have more
robust benefits even when you look at
some of the products that are offered in
the individual market versus those in
the large group market you'll see narrow
networks in the individual market in new
hampshire you don't see neural networks
in the group market generally speaking
and that's because it's just harder to
get a consensus about what hospitals
you're going to leave out what benefits
you're going to reduce and even the
discussion about state mandates which
ones do you want to throw out try to get
any large group of people to agree to
that it's just hard to do
so there are certain practical
challenges i think both regulatory and
practical challenges to to get to a
point where i think the employers are
going to see the savings they might be
looking for under this bill and i think
that being said i think i'm happy to
take questions and uh
about the bill representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
um
mr brennan would it be fair to say that
a two-year pilot program um is a very
short period of time
it would be um we'd have to work pretty
efficiently we'd have to develop a
product that people wanted to enroll in
really quickly and demonstrate
real savings i think for them to do it
that follow up for the question main
query thank you would it also be fair to
say that um when within any insurance
product um your claims don't come all
don't all come in
in the first six months
um you could have serious ones where
only a thousand people
in a group um you're talking very small
you wouldn't have too many cancer
patients to blow the premium would that
be fair yeah i think that's that's a
good point so to the extent you would
develop kind of in this and we make
reference to this association health
plan model which could take a lot of
different variations we'd have to make
some decisions about that preferably
with some legislative intent but to the
extent it's structured and then the
carriers price it we're negotiating
perhaps that price but you can't really
then there's got to be the claims
experience for them to actually come up
with a new premium and generally
speaking when you look at the markets
over time if there's more uncertainty on
the behalf of a carrier they're more
likely to put in padding and make it
more expensive they just don't want to
lose they tend to be very risk adverse
so i think you're right that sort of
getting to a point where there's clearly
demonstratable savings a product that
people want to buy and it's better than
what they're getting now or at least
what's offered by the carriers that
could take some time
for the question main car just one more
question um and even if a reinsurance
policy were in place
to make this acceptable um would it be
likely that this premium would be low
and would they be running into the same
kinds of problems that the underlying
would have
so while the bill doesn't say
specifically i think we're talking about
fully insured business so to the extent
where we're you know it's it's um you've
got all those sort of rating concerns
but again we're stuck in that small
group rating model that three to one
ratio the mandates are there so how much
flexibility have we got i mean probably
the easiest place to start is develop a
narrow network model for the small
employer market um that might be the
sort of straightforward way of kind of
scaling back the costs associated with
but it's probably not something those
employers want to roll with that's going
to be the challenge
representative
thank you mr chair thank you take my
question
um it sounds like it's going to take a
lot of your time
i read the methodology and it sounds
like
it's not going to take up too much time
are you can you explain
what you'll be doing
yeah so you implement this pilot program
the bill is pretty thin so i think
simply to satisfy the requirements of
the bill this is not a massively
resource intensive investment but to get
to a point where you've got a product
that's going to be less expensive a
success in other words you're right it
could be quite it could be quite
involved
so
yes represent van gaal
thank you mr brennan um given that this
is a short-term pilot
and that people who enroll
may end up nowhere in the end is there
any kind of a safety net to a pilot that
may be floundering
and i'm not assuming that it would
flounder but a pilot by virtue of
definition may or may not succeed
i think that's that's fair um it's
probably more relevant to the miwa bill
because there they're actually you're
you're you've got sort of federal laws
that prevent you from from from i think
creating these separate risk pools and
that's true for this bill as well but um
if you anticipate a change at the
federal level and then the ability to
sort of manipulate those risk pools then
it um it does get pretty complicated and
you've got employers that perhaps left
that small group market went into this
alternative arrangement and every year
they're always going to look at my
better off in the standard market am i
better off in this other arrangement and
they're going to go where it's less
expensive and they get more benefits so
if you you know if you don't want them
just going back and forth all the time
then you might put in certain guardrails
about how quickly they can go back and
forth how much stability you might have
to the risk pool but that itself would
be a compromise for the employers who
might want to make those choices every
year
sure
so um of course when i was reading it
that it was a me was but it's not
because
i think from a practical story
standpoint i look at them similarly i
mean hp could take on a number of
different variations i mean one option
is you're simply coming together as a
bunch of employer groups you're buying
everything from the health insurance
carrier another alternative is no you're
actually taking on some of those
responsibilities from the insurance
carrier you're doing your own
negotiation with health care providers
you're developing prescription drug
formulas you're doing a lot of things
the carriers might otherwise that might
look more like one model or the other i
mean to me and me was much more sort of
that multi it's it's not just insurance
it's you know you've got multiple
employer welfare arrangements that may
have benefits outside of insurance
right and but this this was more modeled
after
the exemption when we did 7-eleven like
the bankers association yeah
i think that's it but it was a group
because it was industry which i know
that retailers and hospitality is
had had been thinking about
um
because
so what is the current meal law now do
we still have one on the books so in
terms of somebody wanting to start a new
one or do we i know we had
bills to
bring the 3000 down to 400. i think
you're thinking of that the purchasing
alliance and there was there's there in
the milwaukee bill there's a requirement
for them to qualify as a purchasing
alliance and it was three thousand i
think it's 500 now and i think that was
moving it even to 250 and and this is
basically lowering the threshold for
creating potentially creating a separate
risk pool again if it were permissible
under federal law which it's not um so
what's the federal loan
the federal law simply requires the
single risk pool in that small group
market not splitting them out and
allowing you to create a separate risk
pool for healthy people that can buy
uh okay help me again but
that's what you're why you're coming
together because you think you're
attracting healthy people
that's i think that's a the fundamental
question is is why what do you expect to
benefit from coming together and if it's
going to be a separate risk pool that's
going to be healthier people and that's
why your premiums are going to be
cheaper that's prohibited now well
obviously yeah right okay if you think
it's a matter of coming together because
you could coordinate efforts you could
come up with a new benefit design that
the insurance companies don't offer
today and you would demand that then
perhaps there's some opportunity there
okay now i got a question that i don't
think anybody's ever asked you
if i wanted to start one of these plans
if i want to start
how much capital do i have to have to
begin to get this thing off the ground
in terms of people who come into the
state and you know let's say tufts came
in and
left and back and merged
what does it cost to get one of these
things up and running in the state of
new hampshire it would depend how it's
structured and how much sort of risk
that organization is taking on um that
is though one of the concerns is that if
you end up with an entity that actually
acts as a middleman is collecting
premiums from those employers right you
have to be concerned around solvency and
that's the reason that's one of the only
examples of why in new hampshire we do
have the ability to regulate self-funded
medias okay
but
at the end of the day you have only two
years and then
the claims history of that two years
could go out
multiple years
the tail
i think that i think the the expectation
that this would result in a lower cost
um health insurance benefit design is is
going to be tough to me very difficult
to meet
bingo
okay any other questions
cnn thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
curtis berry
left the room
okay
you might just go out there and find out
curtis perry and tell him that he's he's
on do you know who he is do you know
okay
so henry value here on behalf of the new
hampshire lodging and restaurant
association
we don't really have a position on the
bill
the new hampshire lodging restaurant
association
is not looking to set up their own
health plan um but they
have been are still interested in
exploring having what the national
restaurant association puts together be
able to sold here in new hampshire it is
sold in some other states
the department was very helpful we met
with the department um
and we're still trying to gather some
information but um
uh we don't really have a position on
this but because
the group is not looking to that was not
the angle you guys were going for yeah
so if the pilot was set up some reason i
thought this was yours no this is not
ours no i know better
thank you
okay
uh well he can i think did we have
okay 286 we have five people in support
and
none opposed and we have in that support
we have
senator
mccarty we have senator bradley
and
what's up and uh with that i will close
um
okay
okay so we are running late so let's
keep moving uh so open up senate bill
287 and
tyler brennan will introduce the bill
for the senator unless somebody's here
from
senator's office saying none okay come
so tyler brandon life and health
director with the new hampshire
insurance department i am introducing
senate bill 287 on behalf of senator
bradley this is a bill that was a
request by the insurance department it
deals with the no surprises act and it
deals with balance billing new hampshire
has a balanced billing protection law on
the books as we have for four years the
no surprises act went to effect in
january of this year so we have a
federal law that applies to insurance
requirements and protects people from
balance billing and surprise billing we
do have a position on the bill we are in
favor of it with the amendment i can go
into my testimony or i can take
questions as i'm introducing it i'm not
sure
what you prefer
um why don't we have you wait
and then come back with your amendment
so let's hear from paul minahan sounds
good who's
in support of the bill
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee for the record paula
minihan senior vice president state
government relations with the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals we do
support senate bill 287 and as the
chairman said as amended by the senate
we understood from previous
conversations with the department of
insurance why this legislation
was introduced and the current law
regarding balance billing is not
consistent with the federal no surprises
act and the department attempted with
the original bill
as introduced to codify in state law the
provisions in the federal law the issue
with the original bill for us for the
hospital association was that there were
some outstanding questions with the
federal regulations that are currently
being challenged in federal courts in
addition senate bill 287 exclu includes
exclusive regulatory authority for the
commissioner of insurance we worked on
the bill with other stakeholders in and
the department
during the senate phase to address some
of those provisions that we had
questions and concerns with and as a
result the bill was amended to reflect
those provisions of the original bill
that all stakeholders could agree to
what i think is important to mention
during these this discussion is that the
patient or the consumer is protected by
the federal regulation as well as the
bill before you there cannot be any
balance billing by an out of network
provider as outlined in this federal no
surprises act further the provider and
payer if there is a dispute can follow
the federal dispute resolution process
once other areas of the federal
regulation are resolved
future legislation can be contemplated
to codify the federal requirements and
that's our position anyway
and we thank you for the opportunity to
testify
okay do we have questions from the
committee yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
i went in for a procedure about a month
ago and um i was surprised to see um
there was a statement in there or a
couple sheets about balanced billing
because i had you know questions and it
really answered a lot of my questions is
that the federal balance billing act or
um i believe it is because as um mr
brannon said um it went into effect in
january so they should be following it
so yeah i bet it was very clear good
thank you good thank you we have been
working with our hospitals to ensure
that they are in compliance um and there
are toolkits that i think they have
tried to um
implement to make it consistent because
i think it's also important for folks
going from place to place that you're
seeing something similar yeah
okay so um what i'd like
rather than having you respond to
the insurance department's amendment i
was going to let let you come up let's
have them introduce their
amendment and then you can come up and
respond to it okay
tyler brennan with the insurance
department and uh thank you again
so before i spend too much time talking
about the differences in the bills i
want to make sure we're all on the same
page closer yeah
i want to make we're all make sure we're
on the same page when we're talking
about balanced billing situations so
when you go into a in-network hospital
you may be seen by a provider you didn't
expect to see or you may not even be
seen by them simply treated pathologist
is a good example anesthesiologist might
be another example and those providers
might be out of network
typically when you see an in-network
provider your deductible your cost
sharing goes up to the amount that the
insurance company has negotiated with
that provider this is substantially
different in most cases than the
providers charge and substantially less
that saves you money on your cost
sharing if you're seen by an out of
network provider there is no agreement
between the insurance company and that
provider and that provider's charge is
now what you're going to be balance
billed for beyond anything the insurer
pays if your benefits are limited enough
the insurer may not even be paying
anything toward that out of network
providers care these are the cases where
you're talking about sort of a surprise
bill or balance billing as it takes up
as it plays out so when new hampshire
passed the law four years ago we did it
with just the four specialties that
you're most likely to see when you're in
an in-network hospital those four
specialties are anesthesiology pathology
radiology or emergency medicine the no
surprises act is much broader includes
any other professional provider you
might see while at an in-network
hospital one of the other things it does
is it says if you go to of network
hospital for emergency services you're
also protected from balance billing and
i think that's the circumstance that is
most relevant to the hospitals or at
least as they're being represented in
new hampshire
most of the time your networks in new
hampshire include all of our hospitals
there are a couple of examples where the
hospitals are out of network primarily
in individual products and they're also
primarily the hca hospitals which are
the for-profit chain that owns frisbee
now frisbee parkland and portsmouth and
they objected to the draft that we had
both in the original bill and what the
insurance department proposed as an
alternative amendment that we thought
might satisfy some of the confusion
around what the federal requirements
would be
what actually came out of the senate is
removing the insurance department from
resolving disputes about how much of
out-of-network provider would be paid if
they're not already in that new
hampshire statute those four specialties
in other words so if there is a dispute
about how much one of those hospitals
might be paid it would go through the
federal dispute resolution process the
actual amount is as it was indicated is
somewhat being challenged part of the
reason for that is because it had a very
straightforward methodology it referred
to this qpa this qualifying payment
amount but it was basically the
in-network median amount the federal
guidance evolved a little bit it said
okay well that's a starting point but
you could actually consider other
arguments the new hampshire law makes
reference to commercially reasonable the
insurance department would hold a public
hearing we'd hear the arguments we'd
look at the data as you know we've got
access to the claims data we can figure
out what is typically paid for health
care services we'd resolve the the the
dispute at a local level through a
public process in the fairest way
possible we also would expect those
insurance companies that we regulate to
pay those out of network providers the
way the bills come over from the senate
is those insurance companies would
essentially be required to pay another
network provider because of this this
federal dispute resolution process
conclusion we as the insurance
department would not be directly
involved again unless it's those four
specialties the new hampshire law has
been successful not only have we been
able to avoid resolving disputes we've
ended up with no more providers jumping
out of the network one thing you want to
you want to avoid doing is disrupting
the apple cart creating an alternative
that's better for either party and
suddenly ending up with providers out of
network that's one of the sort of
successes that we've we have avoided we
think similarly we can do that going
forward
part of the reason we asked for this
bill is because at least historically
there's been a lot of legislative
interest in maintaining local local
control at the state level and insurance
is regulated at the state level
so to the extent that we're looking for
kind of a continued role in protecting
new hampshire consumers making sure
insurance companies pay for these health
care services and either way keeping the
patient out which i think is a notable
point i mean either way federal state
the patient shouldn't get pulled into it
of course if they do we're going to
refer them to the federal government
never a place you want to be as a
state-based insurance regulator
so
it's um that's the reason we're in favor
but again it's based on history and of
support for new hampshire
based
solutions
and um
we're happy to give you the language
that we had proposed that would modify
this the original bill to make it more
flexible so any sort of resolution that
takes place at the federal level we
could adapt to that at the end of the
day we'd still be listening to the
parties we'd be just making a
determination about what that payment
level should be based on arguments based
on the data we have in new hampshire and
happy to take any questions you have
and how many complaints have we had with
our new system zero we have had none of
those four specialties petition the
department i would also add that it
doesn't you know our role in this
doesn't need to come through a dispute
we look at network advocacy we make sure
the insurance carriers are actually
including the providers in their network
if they have left out a key provider
then we would ask or one providers that
needs to be in the network to meet
network adequacy we'd say have you made
a commercially reasonable offer carriers
know that so it's not just manual to
handle through the dispute legitimate
process we do put pressure on the
carriers but no we have not had to
resolve any disputes through our public
hearing process
representative bertolt
thank you mr chair
okay
tyler you know i have to write very fast
to keep up with you i'm sorry i could
slow down a little bit
um
i i would you help me with the lay of
the land the bill came in
where the insurance department was still
the referee if you will
then it was amended to
comply with the federal law is that
correct and now you want to go back to
the original
um
bill as it had been filed is that so
there is the original bill it says very
black and white we go with that federal
process
there were two amendments discussed one
is we remove the insurance department
from the disputes
presumably it defaults to whatever
federal process they decide and that's
that's what came out of the senate the
alternative was let's soften the
language in the original bill let's give
a little more flexibility let's still
make reference to that federal dispute
resolution process but let's keep the
insurance department involved in the
middle of these disputes so that for
their services that are not currently in
new hampshire law we continue to play a
role and we make sure our insurance
companies pay those out of network
providers okay mask development for the
question being carter okay so then
if you if you go back to amend it soften
the language a little bit
um so the insurance department continues
to be the referee but still has to
comply with
the federal
guideline or the federal law
um as it is
but it's in dispute right now how does
that
affect
what you would have to do
in the future to amend this bill or
do we wait right so
what's being disputed obviously by the
providers is how much they're going to
get paid so we as third of the referee
in this would take a look at that
whatever the federal process ends up
being and say is that a fair process
should we hear additional arguments
what we have to do as a state is we have
to be at least as consumer protective as
the federal law
so we couldn't just say yeah pay the
provider more i mean the cost sharing
will go up and we're all happy except
the insurance companies that would be
that would not be as protective as that
federal law so as long as we are as
protective as the federal law and all
intents and purposes we're going to be
looking at what that federal decision
would be we might consider local
information that we have both the claims
data the arguments that we hear going
forward and act as a neutral party um
but you know it's it's i think to the
extent there's concern about where the
federal government is going to land the
language that we've proposed would allow
us to be flexible wherever they land and
still resolve it at the local level
and then one more question
thank you sorry
um
in trying to refresh my memory i do
remember when we passed this bill four
years ago regarding the four specialties
those who
i know the reference to the insurance
department but i don't remember who in
the insurance department would be the
referee if there were a case that had to
go further yeah as you know in most
insurance laws it refers to the
insurance commissioner and that's how
it's structured there that being said
the insurance commissioner does almost
nothing on his own i mean we've got to
leave a lot of resources in the
department we would support that process
and the decision and obviously listen to
the arguments that each of the parties
would make
because that's a concern is there a
hearings officer involved
yes
there is okay
okay thank you does the deputy get
involved and
who else gets involved
um the specific process of public of a
hearing might be better answered by
michelle
it's but there
you would be able to draw on the
resources of the department we actually
modified the hearing rules because we
knew in the balance billing legislation
passed a few years ago one of the
reasons the insurance department was put
in the middle is because we have access
to the claims data we can look at what
was paid for the same type of service
across the network over time
but the actual sort of end of the day
decision is still you know it follows
those that that here at the hearing
rules which would involve the hearing
officer and the process
representative fargo
yes and thank you
i think i understand it but the bill we
have today is this
with what amendment is this the original
bill or is this the original bill in the
first amendment or is
yeah is the amendment that you are
suggesting to give
more flexibility and share
not written yet so
it's in the original bill that was
introduced to this yeah what's a little
confusing is the bill is relatively long
most of it are relatively minor
technical changes just to align new
hampshire laws with the federal process
but the key provision of it which is
resolving the disputes
for any of the services not already
covering new hampshire law the insurance
department is not involved we would like
to see the insurance department involved
so that's the amendment we would propose
oh so you're
so there will be an amendment
to what we will it's not here yet gus an
amendment in the subcommittee
but the amendment uh you if you wanted
to see what it's going to basically look
like is look up the bill as introduced
okay yes
okay thank you tyler great all right
so paula you want to tell us why
you think
this version is better than the
um thank you
i don't usually comment on amendments
that i have not seen and it sounds like
no one you have read the original bill
the original bill has introduced what
was wrong with that bill
as my testimony indicated um we do have
concerns about the
authority um the sole authority of the
department of insurance commissioner
nothing against the commissioner that we
have that has nothing to do with that
it's just
again as tyler said no one has gone
through this process we also asked for
an appeal process
remember the hospitals or the providers
are not regulated by the department of
insurance insurers are
the hospitals are regulated by the
department of hhs it is uncomfortable
when you if you would think about that
for a hospital and by the way um i don't
quite know what that comment was about
hca hospitals all i represent all the
hospitals and they all support
the position that i testified on we
support the amended bill so i just want
to be on record
um
so
the
we have concerns about that process it
has not been used we we asked for more
of an appeal
process to consider that the qualified
payment amount which is qpa which is
what tyler was referencing that's what's
being
challenged if you will at the federal
level has not been resolved yet so
that is of concern to us as well um and
hopefully you know we won't need to use
this um and but we do have the federal
process
in in regulation and that is what the
hospitals need to follow so i just want
to reassure people that that the
independent dispute resolution process
if there were
an issue if there could if there is an
issue
that process kicks in and that is a
process that the parties the carrier and
the provider
mutually select the certified
independent dispute resolution
individual um or
company whatever it is um the
the the qualified individual to do that
dispute resolution um that is that is
just dif very different that and i i'm
sure you can appreciate that it's just
very the provider's perspective is just
that those two things are not resolved
so let's put into statute
in state statute what is not disputed um
and and everyone's comfortable with and
let's wait for the federal process to
and the federal challenges to end and
then we have another
another session and when those things
get resolved and i'm sure another bill
could come forward but we are not
comfortable with the process
as i have not looked at the amendment
but if it's the original bill
that's why we
testified ins with concerns about the
original bill that's why we had numerous
conversations um with the stakeholders
and the department which we appreciate
but we never got to
a place where everyone could say let's
support this this change so that's why
the
modified or amended bill was passed
that's
given that there is no federal insurance
commissioner what would the process be
on the federal side
since we we went to we walked through
all the things that would happen here on
the state side right in terms of the
hearings
it would
the
federal independent dispute resolution
process would kick in like i said they
would
i mean i i can get you more
documentation but do we have any
experience with that have does the
hospital have no
not to date this would be a new entity
it just started and it just never had a
federal dispute for anything else not to
mine not in new hampshire so this is
going to be brand spanking new um but
i'm sure others other parts of the
country they have but the independent
dispute resolution process that is those
entities have existed because other
states
companies have used exactly so that's
not new um those entities are not new we
just have not had that experience okay
representative bartlett
thank you mr chair so
what if i know that thing's in the way
so
what
in that the um independent dispute
resolution is parts of it or in court
right now or or whatever wherever it is
what if we didn't pass anything on this
right now
um
because it is so new
and
there are problems
with how it would be handled would it
make sense
to wait until whatever these issues are
settled and then
come back
and
propose a new bill if necessary
um that would be our preference um the
independent dispute resolution
process represented bartlett is not i
don't think that is being challenged in
court it's the qpa it's how you
calculate the qualified payment amount
that's a new term we don't use that in
new hampshire um i wrote that down okay
but qpa and i can get you more
information about the there are some
fact sheets on no surprises act which i
i can bring tomorrow
which i think might be helpful um and
maybe tyler has the same but um i'm
happy to pull that together thank you
yep
okay representative later um thank you
very much i'm a little bit confused if
the
the federal
uh law against uh
gets passed and we and these things are
resolved would we really need a state
law
that is for i think
for you the general court to decide the
department has a position that they want
that to be codified in state law
because we already have a balanced
billing law it's in um it's not
consistent and i obviously don't
represent the department they should
speak to that just so you know in other
states um they they have not implemented
a state law to your point if the federal
law
kind of you know is is in existence
and they don't have a state law
that's fine it just defaults to the
federal process so i think i know where
you're going but i i
i believe
at least testimony from the department
is that they want there to be
consistency with because we already have
a balanced billing law that tyler
already outlined it's it's limited but
they want to make sure that it the
federal and the state
laws are codified we did not have again
we don't have a problem with putting it
into state law the issue is when there
is when there's the it doesn't
completely codify you know if you're
making some changes
just like further questioning well the
only difference i would see is that
these things would be maybe resolved on
a local level
and maybe that's more convenient as as
the insurance department seemed to say
is the only difference i could see am i
wrong there
the
um
way that the qpa is potentially
considered
that calculation i am this is not my
area of expertise um but
that may be different um and the
independent dispute resolution
component is different
because we don't have that in this state
i think some states may
or they use arbitration
but we
we have chosen not to do that
per se um so again we just we had
discussions good fruitful discussions it
just didn't develop in a
full-blown new amendment that everyone
could agree to but um we're certainly
happy to continue discussions with the
department of insurance and the
stakeholders to make sure everyone's
comfortable the bottom line is the
providers are just not comfortable right
now with the with the
process as outlined
that's really the bottom line
okay
any other questions from the committee
members seeing none thank you very much
does anybody else would like to testify
henry
you will fill out a card later won't you
i will thank you mr chairman uh for the
record my name is henry value
and i'm here on behalf of hospital
corporation of america
and i i just have uh to answer your
question directly
um i can tell you the independent
dispute resolution process okay here's
how it is outlined
on the federal level
um
it brings in a third party known as a
certified independent dispute resolution
entity to decide the payment amount
the parties mutually select the
certified independent dispute resolution
entity and everyone involved must attest
to having no conflicts of interest
and requires the provider or the
facility and health plan to submit
payment offers to the certified
independent dispute resolution entity
and additional information supporting
their payment offers
and then it requires the certified
independent dispute resolution entity to
select from the payment offers
both the provider or facility and the
health plan must abide by the certified
entities decision and payment must be
made within 30 calendar days
parties to a dispute reserve priorities
to a dispute use a new federal
independent speech resolution portal
which will open in 2022
so that's how it is designed on the
federal level
and
why i think as paula mentioned we don't
think that the dispute resolution
uh needs to be part of this bill uh
because it has already been addressed on
the federal level
um and that's all i wanted to just
answer your question directly appreciate
it thank you
okay
[Music]
287 we had 52 people in support and
unopposed
and with that
hey henry could you mind filling out a
couple cards
the two of them that you did just so
we have them on record
okay
we'll open up the public hearing on
senate bill 340 and hear from the prime
sponsor
senator daniels
and uh for the record uh this was my
very first liquor bill
this direct ship is uh
well maybe it was my second one i think
but i remember
i remember negotiating with the beer
distributors on this legislation way
back when
so good afternoon mr chairman members of
committee some things never go away do
they
um
for the record my name is gary daniels
i'm a state senator for district 11
representing the towns of wilton milford
amherst in merrimack
also the prime sponsor of senate bill
340 which has to do with the direct
very simply uh
i've i have a
distributor a beer distributor in my
district who had come close to the cap
on what was being allowed to be
direct shipped which was 27
gallons and so i went
to the liquor commission we had a
discussion uh as to what we might be
able to increase that volume to so that
we don't have a business that that we're
stifling at at a certain point uh we
came to a mutual agreement that uh 50
gallons
of beer would be good this is for
in-state and out-of-state direct
shippers and so that's all the bill does
so how many cases of beer is that
well
do the math
uh i think i figured out with 27 gallons
it was like a can and a half a beer
it wasn't much i mean one good super
okay
any questions from the committee members
see none thank you
and i assume i have a card from scott
who is in opposition to the bill good
afternoon
uh my name is scott shire i work for new
hampshire beer distributor just pull
mike close
so better so the dragon speak gets you
okay
so um anyway um as senator daniels just
said this bill was initially introduced
and
was affecting
beer wine and spirits across the board
as introduced it did not have muster
to pass out of senate commerce so it was
amended
twice the second amendment was a floor
amendment
senator daniels brought
and he had an opportunity to work with
the liquor commission the day before but
no other
industry groups were part of that
conversation and i think that our
concern is that this is singling out
one sector of the total beverage alcohol
industry in new hampshire and
we don't necessarily agree with that
approach i think it's been
pointed out by the liquor commission
that
no
existing new hampshire business with a
direct to consumer license right now is
hit the ceiling of the limits we did a
lot of uh changes last year with sb 125
which your committee supported
changing
permissions and
privileges for direct to consumer
shipments for producers of all sizes and
there's also some potential issues with
litigation regarding not treating all
entities in the industry equally
constitutional issues that deal with the
grand home case which um you've probably
heard about from the liquor commission
before so um
we're all about fair market competition
and and regulation i would consider the
liquor commission's comments um during
the hearing
on the senate side and
happy to send some written testimony
over to everybody
via email and i'll make sure the clerk
has it as well
that's really all i wanted to say at
this time i just want to make sure that
everybody's
looking at this thing equally
so your opposition is because
it's only beer not including the alcohol
is that the reason your opposition i'm
just make sure i understand we actually
had no input when this floor amendment
we had no opportunity to meet with the
liquor commissioner senator david here's
your chance give us your input tell us
tell us what's wrong why this is a bad
idea like i said it should treat all
entities equally
and i think there's concern about
litigation when you don't
that's it okay
thank you
and she hand up yes representative
johnson
so if if
because it just addresses just the beer
manufacturers
would you be
open for an amendment that basically
just opens it up for 50 gallons for
all
beer wine and spirits well i certainly
can't speak for other industry members
that may or may not have been consulted
on this but i would say that for us
it's it's an equity a parity and a
fairness issue so that would certainly
be better than not being involved in the
decision-making process uh at this point
uh i can assure you that the liquor
commission would be in opposition for us
to change these numbers
so
thank you mr chairman and thank you sir
for for testifying i guess i'm confused
as to who you actually represent because
you are now presented with the body that
can actually change legislation
and yet you are hesitant or reluctant
for whatever reason to provide us
with what you would like to see
uh
you know who who was not consulted and
what would they
what would they want in here
what was left out
i i'm i'm perplexed
and then
i guess what do you want yeah well
thanks for the question it's a good one
um we really think that the limits are
fine where they are there's no need to
modify them nobody's hit the ceiling um
and i think this was brought on behalf
of one brewery um in the state which is
in senator daniel's district um and
they're not even a member of the brewers
association in the state um there was
not any support from the brewers
association for this either and i do not
know if there was support or not from
the winemakers association or the
distilled spirits craft association in
the state so i think those groups should
be involved in the process and there was
a reason this had an interim study vote
initially and i think it probably needs
representative pilot
thanks mr chair um will the liquor
commission be here tomorrow
uh
probably
okay
so that yes so
yes i know i know why the liquor
commission has a problem
how much money do you really make on a
case of beer
how much does a beer distributor make
it depends on what what question you're
asking you talking about wholesale
margin you talking about well i'm saying
i'm saying you know that that the issue
when it comes to
distilled and wines and everything
through you know the the electric
commission
has a uh
five percent tax
and on wine and eight percent distilled
and that they've always that that number
is pretty low we're not really making a
lot of money
in this case when it comes to beverages
everybody still pay the 30 cents a
gallon still gets paid correct so the
state doesn't lose anything
the only person who's losing out if a
beer distributor manufacturer is
distributing themselves
is uh you guys get screwed because
you're not getting to deliver that beer
and i've just
you know
i guess you can't you can't really tell
me that's a
corporate secret how much a case of beer
is but i can't imagine that that
at 12 cases of beer that there's that
much money on the table that you would
be upset about having some beverage
manufacturer deciding that they decide
that they don't want to go through
distribution that they want to
self-distribute
which which at the end of the day that's
the original intent of the legislation
was to allow manufacturers to
self-distribute this is different from
self-distribution right this is
direct-to-consumer distribution
self-distribution is to licensed
accounts right and they have a 2500
barrel limit on that which is much much
higher
i think the other point that was made
regarding the five percent uh tax
revenue on wine and the eight percent on
spirits whether that's shipped direct to
consumer or shipped through the liquor
commission the state's gonna get paid
anyway they still collect the tax eighty
percent right on the direct consumer
shipments so it's the same same argument
for beer right the taxes we're still
going to get the eight percent right
you're still getting at the eight
percent so yeah
or or the state in you know by the state
peeling out
wine and spirits out of this bill when
they amended it
that you know that doesn't necessarily
protect them
or you know create any more revenue for
them because they can still get the
revenue if it's sold by an out-of-state
entity shipped into us to you know
representative hunt in uh in rindge uh
they're still gonna get paid so that
argument doesn't necessarily hold water
um
with regard they were happy because we
put in that if you ship
more than a thousand bottles to somebody
then you had to make it offer available
to the commission
which nobody's you know you're you're
not worried about whether these these
beverage manufacturers make it available
for you to sell
well i think you know to answer that
question we're certainly not worried
about the liquor commission's business
model when it comes to wine and spirits
you know we're more concerned about
three-tier system relative to beer and
you know sort of the the regulatory
changes that were set up you know in the
past and continue to be modified over
the years it works pretty well and
there's no real reason to change the
limits you're going to change it change
it for everybody got him all right
representing
thank you for testimony
uh you made a reference to the issue of
fairness with the other industries with
beer and spirits or wine and spirits and
the current limit is 27 gallons is that
correct
i believe so yes so could you explain
how the current limit is fair
that 27 gallon limit how is that fair
currently with the other
liquor
industries one and one in spirits
i wouldn't say that it's necessarily
fair and i don't know what the
justification was when those numbers
were come up with representative hunt
would probably have a better idea
because it was quite a while ago but i
will tell you that those numbers have
been fixed for decades and i think to
arbitrarily change one of those
categories up and not address the other
ones i'd like to know what the rationale
is for that i mean we don't we don't
we're not hitting limit for beer
i don't know if we're hitting the limit
for wine or for spirits but the liquor
commission might have that data and i
think we should make those decisions
based on you know on facts and need not
for the question
but the current number is arbitrary you
admit that is that right
like i said i wasn't involved when that
number was chosen um it probably there
was some calculation that seemed to be
logical at the time but again i was not
here when that happened so i couldn't
tell you but a lot of things in statute
and a rule do seem to be fairly
arbitrary i think the 2000 barrel limit
the 2500 barrel limit we're sort of all
sort of pie in the sky we just oh that
sounds like a pretty good number let's
let's go with it so i can't necessarily
comment but i can tell you that
based on the report the liquor
commission did prior to the senate
hearing they ran all these reports and
nobody was bumping up against the limit
i think i know how many how much beers
in a in a keg big keg
uh 50 liter keg
like about seven cases worth of beer
seven 24 12 ounce cases all right i
remember somehow i remember clark
talking about cases of a keg of a beer
but
that's that's that's as good as my
memory will let me go i'm right there
with you okay
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you so anybody else would like to
testify on senate bill 340.
we have
uh
three in support and one person who is
neutral
neutral oh jamie burnett
the wine institute okay
all right and with that we'll close the
public hearing
and that's it for our public hearings so
as everybody knows we've got
subcommittees tomorrow
uh and theoretically we'll try to get
through everything that we have i've
scheduled an exec session for next
wednesday afternoon
that leaves
potentially wednesday morning open for
anything that doesn't get resolved
tomorrow
and
these are all scheduled for the
subcommittee tomorrow uh so anything
that gets left is a loose end we can
still do it and
and still this gives us some time before
uh we have to have every bill out of
committee
uh
yeah i i
you know yeah i guess i didn't pay
enough attention to the order that they
were in the vast majority of the bills
we had we had where we didn't we didn't
have too many liquor bills there was
just what had you know two of them
so so that they were just kind of thrown
in um but you know about most is
insurance in business so but i i really
urge everyone to show up and just you
know just to follow what we're doing and
where we're at and and and we we allow
everybody to participate and you know
obviously when it gets to the actual
voting mode of the subcommittee it's
limited but
i i still i
urge everyone to
be
so
yep
nice
um
ah out of the 400 emails that i've
received over the last three four days
probably
and there are some things that have this
high pressure
originally
yes